programming throwdown episode 181 memory management take it away Patrick Welcome to another episode of programming throwdown. My topic, I guess it's the opening rant. Yeah. It's okay. I'm curious, actually don't, I didn't talk to you about this before we recorded, so this is live on air. Video game prices. Alright, so everyone's like a different kind of video gamer, They're not a video gamer, casual, whatever. And I get that. But then it's really interesting specifically when we're recording this is right around the launch time of the Switch 2. So we have to say this now because 10 years from now people will be like, what are they talking about?
Programming Throwdown 第 181 期：内存管理。Patrick，开始吧。欢迎收听新一期的 Programming Throwdown。我的话题，我想应该是开场吐槽。好吧，没问题。其实我很好奇，我们在录音前没聊过这个，所以这是现场直播。电子游戏的价格。好吧，每个人对电子游戏的看法都不一样，有人不是玩家，有人是休闲玩家，等等。我理解这一点。但特别有趣的是，我们录制这期节目的时间正好在 Switch 2 发布前后。所以我们现在必须说出来，因为 10 年后人们会问，他们在说什么？
But the Switch 2 is coming out and there's been a lot of chatter online, in people I see at work and about the price of the system, probably reasonable, but the price of the games were considered more expensive. So sort of like 80 USD dollars to 90 USD dollars. So just for my edification, what's the price of the system? Cause I'm not in the loop on this. Oh, I don't have it in front of me.
但 Switch 2 即将发布，网上以及我在工作中见到的人都在讨论这款主机的价格，可能还算合理，但游戏的价格被认为更贵了。大概是 80 到 90 美元。为了增长见识，主机的价格是多少？因为我没关注这个。哦，我手头没有具体数据。
Roughly, yeah. Yeah, I think $ Uh, I don't have it in front of me. Roughly. Yeah. Yeah. I think $400. Okay. And what was the switch one? Was it cheaper than that? Uh, I think like $50 cheaper. Okay.
大概吧。是的，我想是 400 美元。好的，那 Switch 1 是多少钱？比这个便宜吗？呃，我想便宜 50 美元左右。好的。
Got it. Okay. It looks like it might be 450 and I think the original switch was 400. That's okay. I don't know because I just opted out, uh, which is part of the part of the rent. So some people are saying, you know, oh, this is, this is inflation or even, you know, when there were super Nintendo and I remember going to a Kmart and super Nintendo games were like, what, they're how expensive?
明白了。看起来可能是 450 美元，我觉得最初的 Switch 是 400 美元。没关系。我不知道，因为我选择了不买，这也是吐槽的一部分。所以有些人说，哦，这是通货膨胀，甚至在超级任天堂时代，我记得去 Kmart，超级任天堂的游戏要多少钱？它们怎么那么贵？
And it was crazy. Um, yeah, like $70, $80. So people are like, well, you know, we're just, we're just kind of whining. And if you look at the number of hours you get, like compared to, let's say, the price of a movie ticket, then, you know, it's a super, you know, good value or price of going to an amusement park or something, right? Like you can kind of make these value propositions.
这太疯狂了。嗯，是的，大概 70、80 美元。所以人们会说，好吧，我们只是在发牢骚。如果你看看你投入的时间，比如和电影票的价格相比，那么，这还是非常划算的，或者和去游乐园之类的相比，对吧？你可以提出这些价值主张。
And what I realized is like price anchoring, price economics, these things are just so complicated. And even in such like, I don't know, a small chasm of the world, uh, that you can end up with such different logical reasons why the price is good or why the price is not good that are consistent for that individual. And then it just leads like to, to, you know, outcomes all over the place. Like, of course I'm going to buy this and here's my rationalization. Or of course I'm not going to buy this and then here's a made up rationalization.
我意识到的是，价格锚定、价格经济学，这些东西太复杂了。即使在这样一个狭小的世界里，你最终也会得出完全不同的逻辑理由，来说明为什么这个价格是好的，或者为什么是不好的，而这些理由对个人来说都是自洽的。然后这就会导致各种各样的结果。比如，我当然会买这个，这是我的合理化解释；或者我当然不会买这个，这是我编造的合理化解释。
And then other people who are legitimately trying to, they're on the fence and they're sort of trying to decide. So I have my sort of opinion on which side I feel this comes down on and my logic, but I wanted to hear from you. Like, do you think in general, like launch price of video games being sort of 70, 80, $90? Like, yeah, that's fine. It's worth it or, oh no, that's way too expensive. So yeah, here's my take on it. I think that the difference between a video game and a movie is that the movie has a higher lower bound. In other words, like a movie can only suck so much.
还有其他人，他们确实在犹豫，试图做决定。所以我对这件事站在哪一边有自己的看法和逻辑，但我想听听你的意见。你认为总的来说，电子游戏 70、80、90 美元的首发价格，是没问题的，物有所值，还是说，哦不，这太贵了？所以，这是我的看法。我认为电子游戏和电影的区别在于，电影有一个更高的下限。换句话说，电影再烂也有个限度。
Oh, that's a bold statement. I mean, like, well, okay, I'll put it to you this way. Have you ever walked out of a theater halfway through a movie? Personally, no, but I see very few movies. Yeah, that's true. I see very few movies as well. But, but, uh, you know, in my lifetime, I've been to movie theater, let's say a hundred times, probably more than that, right? My entire life. And I have never walked out of a movie.
哦，那是个大胆的说法。我是说，好吧，我换个方式问你。你有没有在电影院看到一半就离场过？个人没有，但我很少看电影。是的，那倒是真的。我也很少看电影。但是，在我的一生中，我去过电影院大概一百次，可能更多，对吧？我从来没有中途离场过。
I've watched every movie start to finish. Right. But you know, video games, it's actually the opposite. Like very few video games do I really sink the full amount of time into. And there's some video games that, you know, I get, the media kit looks really good, and the trailer looks really good, and I play it, and it's okay. You know, it's not terrible. I don't return it or anything, but it's just like,
我把每一部电影都从头看到了尾。对吧。但电子游戏，情况恰恰相反。很少有游戏我能真正投入全部时间。有些游戏，媒体套件看起来很棒，预告片看起来很棒，我玩了之后，觉得还行。你知道，不算糟糕。我没有退货什么的，但就是……
it just doesn't hold me and so I let it go. And so, you kind of like invest into the whole experience more than a single game, right? And so, you know, the analogy of like, oh, well, if you take your favorite game, you sunk, like in my case, what's the game I played the most? Maybe, I don't know, Rocket League or Rimworld or something, I don't know.
它就是吸引不了我，所以我放弃了。所以，你投入的是整个体验，而不仅仅是一款游戏，对吧？所以，那个类比，哦，如果你拿你最喜欢的游戏，你投入了，以我为例，我玩得最多的是什么？也许是《火箭联盟》或《边缘世界》之类的，我不知道。
Let's say I put a thousand hours into Rocket League and I paid 20 bucks or whatever. Now it's free to play, but I paid whatever I paid when it came out. Well yeah, I totally got my money's worth, but that doesn't count all the games that I bought that I wasn't really that interested in.
假设我在《火箭联盟》里投入了一千个小时，我付了 20 美元还是多少。现在它是免费游戏了，但我刚出来时付了钱。好吧，确实物有所值，但这没算上我买的那些我其实没那么感兴趣的游戏。
And so if every game costs $80, now you have this paradox where, I didn't know that I was gonna be really into Rocket League. I wouldn't have spent eighty dollars on it. And so it just it just wouldn't have happened. And so. I think that's the real challenge. So, you know, for example, like I could see Madden football, you know,
所以如果每款游戏都要 80 美元，现在你就面临一个悖论：我不知道我会那么喜欢《火箭联盟》。我不会花 80 美元去买它。所以这根本就不会发生。所以我认为这是真正的挑战。所以，例如，我能理解《麦登橄榄球》，你知道，
it's like Madden football is a known entity and there's a cohort of people who And there's a cohort of people who are going to sink a thousand hours into every Madden football, every single one. Right. And so, yeah, they should probably pay like a hundred bucks. Right. But, but that's like a small part of the audience, I think. I wanted to, I wanted to challenge you, like really a thousand hours when it comes out every year. And then I realized, no, actually, yeah, you're probably right. There are probably people who play 20 hours every week. Yeah, I mean, but even if we knock it down to 200, then you can still say, okay, 200 hours,
《麦登橄榄球》是一个已知的实体，有一群人会把一千个小时投入到每一款《麦登橄榄球》中，每一款都是。对吧。所以，是的，他们可能应该付 100 美元。对吧。但我觉得那只是受众的一小部分。我想挑战你，真的每一款出来都要玩一千个小时吗？然后我意识到，不，其实你是对的。可能确实有人每周玩 20 个小时。是的，我是说，即使我们把它降到 200 小时，你仍然可以说，好吧，200 小时，
you should pay a hundred bucks for that. But it's the problem is you just don't know. So I think I'm on board with your reasoning. I mean, I will say, I guess, to stick up for the other side that not every game will be that expensive. So you can still have games that are probably priced less. But as a prototypical example, I hear you out.
你应该付 100 美元。但问题是你根本不知道。所以我认为我同意你的推理。我是说，为了支持另一方，我得说并不是每款游戏都会那么贵。所以你仍然可以买到价格较低的游戏。但作为一个原型例子，我听懂了你的意思。
For me, the kind of issue is realizing two things. Specifically that Nintendo prices seem to stay up on their game. So if you sort of look like you said, like at Madden, if you buy last year's Madden, you wouldn't pay anywhere near $80 or whatever. You'd be like 30 bucks, 20 bucks, 10 bucks. Yeah, it's perishable.
对我来说，问题在于意识到两件事。特别是任天堂的游戏价格似乎一直居高不下。所以如果你像你说的看《麦登》，如果你买去年的《麦登》，你根本不用付 80 美元。大概只要 30、20 或 10 美元。是的，它是易腐品。
They need to play it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But there are other games similarly that will launch and then just discount over time slowly and assuredly go down. Although famously, Factorio does the opposite, I guess, only goes up. Good for them, breaking trends.
他们需要玩它。是的，是的。但也有其他游戏在发布后会慢慢打折，稳步下降。尽管众所周知，《异星工厂》恰恰相反，只会涨价。为他们点赞，打破常规。
But I think they had a reverse sale once. No, maybe that was Cards Against Humanity. Someone did a reverse sale once. Nice. maybe that was Cards Against Humanity. Someone did a reverse sale once. Nice. Where it made stuff more expensive for a day. But yeah, for me, it's, Nintendo prices seem to like come in high and stay high. And it's exactly the reasons,
但我记得他们有一次反向促销。不，那可能是《红牌大乱斗》。有人做过一次反向促销。不错。那可能是《红牌大乱斗》。有人做过一次反向促销。不错。就是让东西在一天内变得更贵。但对我来说，任天堂的价格似乎总是很高，而且一直保持高位。这正是原因，
when I end up playing them in general, I find them to be very high quality, which mitigates the risk you're saying, where like you end up not putting the number of hours into it. And I don't spend that many hours a week in general. So it's very like a game will either increase the number of hours I spent in the week
当我最终玩它们时，我通常发现它们的质量非常高，这减轻了你所说的风险，即你最终没有投入那么多时间。而且我通常每周花的时间也不多。所以这很像，一款游戏要么会增加我每周投入的时间，
or just fit into the budget I already have. But the contrast I had is if you take something like playing on your computer or a Steam Deck or something else, even one of the Android gaming devices now that they have. And you look at the prices there and picking up stuff on deals that are like indie games or whatever and just like games that are again a year or two old, prices seem to be so much lower. So this fact of like the same game released on iOS, Android, Nintendo Switch, and PC,
要么就刚好符合我现有的预算。但我对比的是，如果你在电脑、Steam Deck 或其他设备上玩，甚至现在他们有的安卓游戏设备。你看看那里的价格，买那些打折的独立游戏，或者一年两年前的游戏，价格似乎要低得多。所以，同一款游戏在 iOS、安卓、任天堂 Switch 和 PC 上发布，
even though it's exactly the same, have such greatly different prices, sort of like kills it to me to be on the platform with the most premium. Like why do I need to be on Nintendo? It's not the most powerful hardware. It's the highest price. Like if you're gonna buy the same library of games,
尽管完全一样，价格却大不相同，这让我觉得在最昂贵的平台上玩简直没意义。为什么我非要在任天堂上玩？它不是性能最强的硬件。它是价格最高的。如果你要买同样的库，
you're going to, on general, pay the most on the Nintendo platform. Like it's just very,, it crushes me. I'm like, oh, I love it. I like what they're doing, but it kind of appeals to me as a casual gamer, but that premium, it really builds up if you're going to buy 10, 15, 20 games even. Yeah, that makes sense. It's kind of like Disney World where it's like, what is it, like $50 to park now?
你通常会在任天堂平台上付最多的钱。这真的让我很崩溃。我喜欢它，我喜欢他们正在做的事情，它作为休闲游戏平台很吸引我，但如果你要买 10、15、20 款游戏，那个溢价真的会累积起来。是的，这说得通。这有点像迪士尼乐园，现在停车费都要 50 美元了吧？
It's like the prices are just getting so out of control and it's like, you know, it is a known quantity. You know that your kids are going to have like a higher lower bound, right? There's a higher minimum amount of fun than if they go to like Six Flags or something. But then it's like so much more expensive. Oh, one game that you recommended as a tool of the show a while back and I
价格简直失控了，而且你知道，这是一个已知量。你知道你的孩子会获得更高的下限，对吧？比起去六旗乐园之类的，这里的乐趣最低限度更高。但它也贵得多。哦，有一款你之前作为节目工具推荐的游戏，我
played through, Tectonica has a very interesting story according to the dev team and this is, you know, in the eye of them. So, so, uh, uh, so take, take it with a grain of salt, but, but they basically said, you know, they did But they basically said, you know, they did one of these things, you know how like Epic and other platforms will have a game free for a week? Yeah.
玩通关了，《Tectonica》的故事非常有趣，根据开发团队的说法，这是他们眼中的故事，所以，听听就好，但他们基本上说，他们做了……他们做了其中一件事，你知道 Epic 和其他平台会有一周免费游戏吗？是的。
Yeah. So the Microsoft Xbox store has this. And so they did all these free games for a week thing. And according to the devs, Microsoft paid them a million dollars to do tectonica for free for some period of time. And, um, and they took the million dollars, but what they said was the sales were just way higher, like so many people got it for free way more than
是的。所以微软 Xbox 商店也有这个。他们做了所有这些一周免费游戏的事情。据开发者说，微软付了他们一百万美元，让他们在一段时间内免费提供《Tectonica》。而且，他们拿了一百万美元，但他们说销量反而高得离谱，很多人免费获得了它，远超
they anticipated. And then it gutted exactly. And then when they tried to, they couldn't recover, basically the free week was so good that they saturated the market. And, um, and so they went out of business and so Tectonica is actually defunct. I didn't know this. Yeah. Yeah.
他们的预期。然后它彻底毁了……没错。当他们试图恢复时，他们无法恢复，基本上免费周太成功了，以至于他们饱和了市场。然后，他们倒闭了，所以《Tectonica》现在实际上已经不存在了。我不知道这个。是的。
The, the ending, uh, I'm not going to spoil like the, the ending, uh, narrative or anything, but, spoil the ending narrative or anything, but the ending is terrible. Technically, the game just falls apart at the end. It's just sort of unfinished. I actually never made, I ate it pretty far, but I know what the ending was supposed to be around, but I never sort of finished it.
结局，我不会剧透结局叙事什么的，但结局很糟糕。从技术上讲，游戏在最后分崩离析了。它只是有点没做完。我其实从来没玩到那，我玩得挺远的，但我知道结局应该是怎样的，但我从来没玩完。
Yeah, the ending is, I didn't finish it either, but I got close enough. Effectively, the ending, it just close enough. There's effectively the ending. It just trails off. It's kind of like, uh, if you lose your voice while you're giving a speech or something, it just kind of whimpers. Um, and it's just because they couldn't finish it. And so to your point, it's like so many people sunk so much time into it, but
是的，结局是，我也没玩完，但我玩得够近了。实际上，结局只是……它只是逐渐消失了。这有点像，如果你在演讲时失声了，它只是有点呜咽。而且这只是因为他们没能做完。所以回到你的观点，很多人投入了那么多时间，但
there was no way to continue to charge, right? Like that's one thing that a lot of these games do is they charge for a hat, which does nothing. It's just cosmetic. But I don't know if it's psychological or how this really works, but even there's single player games where you could buy a hat. Nobody's going to see it but you. But if you can get some way to get people to pay once they're invested in the game, I think that might be the way to unlock the value.
没有办法继续收费，对吧？这是很多游戏会做的一件事，他们为一顶帽子收费，那帽子什么用都没有。只是装饰性的。但我不知道这是心理学还是怎么运作的，但即使是单机游戏，你也可以买帽子。没人会看到它，只有你自己。但如果你能找到某种方法，让人们在投入游戏后付费，我认为那可能是解锁价值的方法。
Okay. So we're way off, we're off topic, getting on other stuff, but the, so the opposite example that I've been trying to figure out, and I guess I, I didn't actually gone and look, but no man's sky. So this was like hyped up beyond anything. It released, people were so frustrated that they had pre-ordered the game and it wasn't as good. but no man's sky. So this was like hyped up beyond anything. It released, people were so frustrated that they had pre-ordered the game and it wasn't as good.
好吧。我们跑题太远了，聊到别的东西去了，但是，我一直在试图弄清楚的相反例子，我想我没去查过，但《无人深空》。这游戏被炒作得无以复加。它发布时，人们非常沮丧，因为他们预购了游戏，但它没那么好。
And then now for like, what, six, seven, I don't even know, like a long time, they basically continued to drop massive DLCs, massive updates. Like I tried playing a while, like it's really complicated. I never really got into it, but like, I mean, they've just continued to like completely change the game. And as far as I know, they've never charged for any of those DLCs. They continue to pump out huge
然后现在，大概六、七年了，我甚至不知道，很长一段时间，他们基本上持续发布了巨大的 DLC，巨大的更新。我试着玩了一段时间，它真的很复杂。我从来没真正沉迷进去，但我的意思是，他们一直在彻底改变这款游戏。据我所知，他们从未对任何 DLC 收费。他们继续推出巨大的
content. They don't have any of the like, you know, in-app purchase stuff going on. So I don't know if they just like made enough money off of the pre-order to basically like coast it in and just do one for humanity. But like, yeah, it's fascinating. It's a, it is really interesting. Okay. Well, that was going to whirlwind time for news. So keeping on the game, game theme, talking about a over 30 year old game, I guess, uh, and super Mario Rose, which is, um, uh, YouTube video actually by
内容。他们没有任何那种应用内购买的东西。所以我不知道他们是不是只是靠预购赚够了钱，基本上可以维持下去，为人类做点贡献。但，是的，这很迷人。这确实非常有趣。好吧，新闻时间真是旋风般地过去了。继续游戏主题，聊聊一款 30 多年前的游戏，我想，还有《超级马里奥兄弟》，这是一个 YouTube 视频，来自
Abyss soft, I think I'm saying it right. Step one, jump in the Lava. In this video, and I've talked about a few of these about like speed running, tool-assisted speed runs, that kind of stuff, is a story about something that happened, I think fairly recently, in the community where someone noticed
Abyss Soft，我想我没读错。第一步，跳进岩浆。在这个视频里，我聊过一些关于速通、工具辅助速通之类的内容，这是一个关于最近在社区里发生的事情的故事，有人注意到
on one of the Super Mario levels that they jumped into the lava in one of the Bowser castles and their game crashed. And they sort of like, you know, posted about it. They just kind of moved on. No one really thought too much about it. And then eventually, you know, people picked up that like, oh yeah, there was this really weird condition
在其中一个超级马里奥关卡里，他们在其中一个库巴城堡跳进了岩浆，然后游戏崩溃了。他们发帖说了这件事。他们只是继续玩下去了。没人太在意。然后最终，人们发现，哦，确实有一个非常奇怪的条件，
where if a certain set of things happen in a certain way in the details of like how enemies are loaded as like the blocks, the kind of sp how enemies are loaded as like the the blocks that kind of sprites that that kind of get put in that dude in this one level out of all the levels where it even potentially could happen there's only this one level have this set up and it would be very very unlikely that you could trigger it but this person happened to to kind of trigger by accident they could explain why and then realize wait a minute there's an
如果一组特定的事情以特定的方式发生，在敌人如何加载的细节中，就像那些方块，那些精灵被放置在那个关卡里，在所有可能发生这种情况的关卡中，只有这一关有这种设置，而且你触发它的可能性非常非常小，但这个人碰巧偶然触发了它，他们能解释原因，然后意识到，等等，有一个
opportunity for arbitrary code execution, which means, hey, you can make the game execute a jump command or a branch command that you can stage by certain inputs. So then through, they call it like tool-assisted speed running, basically bots that like perfectly time their inputs and do things that a human never could from timing or even input standards, they were able to basically put certain values in
任意代码执行的机会，这意味着，嘿，你可以让游戏执行一个跳转指令或分支指令，你可以通过特定的输入来安排它。所以通过他们所谓的工具辅助速通，基本上是机器人完美地计时输入，做人类永远无法做到的事情，无论是从计时还是输入标准来看，他们基本上能够把特定的值放在
the place that would get read and cause the game to just jump to the ending. Um, and sort of like that counts as completing the game for any percent speed runs and then the challenge of sort of like getting humans to, to kind of like, could they do it? Would it be possible? Is there a setup that physically a human could input the inputs to get it to happen? And this is not the only example
会被读取的地方，导致游戏直接跳转到结局。嗯，这算作完成游戏，用于任意百分比速通，然后挑战就是让人们去尝试，他们能做到吗？这可能吗？有没有一种设置是人类物理上可以输入这些指令来实现的？这并不是唯一一个
of these arbitrary code executions occurring in these video games, but just crazy to me that somebody just stumbled upon it after all these years, how much detail people went into to like debug, you know, the super old code from assembly to understand why it was happening, and then to realize that you could set it up such that the game technically is crashing,
在这些电子游戏中发生任意代码执行的例子，但对我来说，有人在这么多年后偶然发现它，人们为了调试那些超级古老的汇编代码，去理解为什么会发生这种情况，然后意识到你可以这样设置，使得游戏在技术上崩溃了，
but it crashes in a way that actually sends you where you want into a valid ending of the video game and plays the ending credits. And so just like one of these. That's awesome. I don't know. Definitely not useful to your life in any way, but just like one of these. That's awesome. I don't know. Definitely not useful to your life in any way, but just like a fascinating watch.
但它崩溃的方式实际上把你送到了你想去的地方，进入了电子游戏的有效结局并播放了制作人员名单。所以这只是其中之一。太棒了。我不知道。绝对对你的生活没有任何用处，但只是……太棒了。我不知道。绝对对你的生活没有任何用处，但只是……一个迷人的观看体验。
And so for some reason, these keep popping up into my feed every so often, even though I've never attempted a speed run. I don't really watch speed running. I don't keep up on it, but I, you know. Have you seen the Final Fantasy 2 one? No. Is it a summoning salt video?
所以出于某种原因，这些视频时不时地出现在我的推送里，尽管我从未尝试过速通。我不怎么看速通。我不关注它，但我，你知道。你看过《最终幻想 2》的那个吗？没有。是 Summoning Salt 的视频吗？
I just like, I watched that one to just go to sleep. It's amazing. It's very meditative. What is that? What is the fun? Oh, go ahead. Yeah, so this one, okay, there's a, there's a spell called exit in most of these Final Fantasy
我只是看那个视频来助眠。太棒了。非常冥想。那是什么？乐趣在哪里？哦，你说吧。是的，所以这个，好吧，有一个叫“逃离”（Exit）的法术，在大多数这些《最终幻想》
games. And so if you're in a cave or a dungeon or someplace as dangerous, or even a town, I think you can cast exit and it will take you to the overland, you know, where you entered. So if you entered the town, you know or even a town, I think you can cast exit and it will take you to the overland, uh, you know, where you entered. So if you entered the town, you know, from the right press exit, you end up at the overland one square to the right. It makes sense. Um, there's, there's another spell called war and war pill more confusing
游戏里。所以如果你在洞穴、地牢或某个危险的地方，甚至城镇里，我想你可以施放“逃离”，它会把你带到大地图，你知道，你进入的地方。所以如果你从右边进入城镇，施放“逃离”，你最终会出现在大地图右边一格。这说得通。嗯，还有另一个法术叫“传送”（Warp），更令人困惑，
where it will do the same thing, but just for one level. So imagine if like you're you walk down a staircase you're in level one of the mines you go down another staircase you're level two of the mines when you cast warp it puts you at level one of the mines you know at the staircase to level two. See what I'm saying? Yep. Okay so now you can't cast there's no stack so you can't like warp and then warp again until you're out. So you cast warp and then if you try and cast it again, it,
它会做同样的事情，但只针对一层。所以想象一下，如果你走下楼梯，你在矿井第一层，你又走下楼梯，你在矿井第二层，当你施放“传送”，它把你放回矿井第一层，你知道，在通往第二层的楼梯口。明白我的意思吗？是的。好的，现在你不能施放，没有堆栈，所以你不能传送然后再次传送直到你出去。所以你施放“传送”，然后如果你尝试再次施放，它，
I think it just doesn't work or something. But anyways, so there's, so for each level they need to keep track of like the level you came from and so there's this one room, or they need to put like a sentinel value there to tell you you can't warp, right? But there's one room in a town in one of these villages where they forgot to put the sentinel value. And so when you warp, you go to like some arbitrary place of memory. And because it's all ROM, it's like completely deterministic. So when you cast warp in like this one room in this palace,
我想它只是不起作用或者什么的。但无论如何，所以对于每一层，他们需要跟踪你来自哪一层，所以有一个房间，或者他们需要在那放一个哨兵值来告诉你不能传送，对吧？但其中一个村庄的城镇里有一个房间，他们忘了放哨兵值。所以当你传送时，你去了内存中某个任意的地方。而且因为全是 ROM，它是完全确定性的。所以当你在宫殿里的这个房间施放“传送”时，
you end up just in like random memory and it's just every sprite is randomly generated. So it's like total chaos, but it's completely deterministic. And so the speed run is like get to this castle as fast as you can, cast warp and then like walk in this very as fast as you can, cast warp, and then like walk in this very specific pattern until you get the end credits. That's so good. Yeah. I feel like in another life, this would be my hobby.
你最终会进入随机内存，每个精灵都是随机生成的。所以这简直是彻底的混乱，但它是完全确定性的。所以速通就是尽快到达这个城堡，施放“传送”，然后以非常特定的模式行走，直到看到制作人员名单。太棒了。是的。我觉得在另一辈子，这会是我的爱好。
Oh, totally. I could see myself spending like a whole lifetime. Yeah. Just figuring this out. I mean, it's like, it's very satisfying. And that is a good segue to what I actually did spend most of my life on, which is reinforcement learning. This is a really interesting reinforcement learning paper. And I'll give a bit of background. So I remember talking to like Trevor Blackwell and like the founders of
哦，完全同意。我能想象自己花一辈子时间。是的。去弄清楚这个。我的意思是，这非常令人满足。这是一个很好的过渡，引出我实际上花了大半辈子研究的东西，也就是强化学习。这是一篇非常有趣的强化学习论文。我会提供一点背景。所以我记得和 Trevor Blackwell 以及 Y Combinator 的创始人们聊过，
Y Combinator. This is like pre-pandemic 2018 or something and saying like reinforcement learning really needs like I said at the time like a BERT moment. I mean this is like pre-GPT pre all that stuff but basically you know BERT at the time was kind of like GPT, where you could embed different sentences and you could finish sentences and everything. And it just felt like a very universal model, like it was multilingual and you could just kind of finish almost any sentence it felt like. And I feel like reinforcement learning needs kind of something like that, where you're not training just totally from scratch.
这大概是疫情前 2018 年左右，我说强化学习真的需要一个像 BERT 那样的时刻。我的意思是，这是在 GPT 之前，在所有那些东西之前，但基本上，你知道，BERT 当时有点像 GPT，你可以嵌入不同的句子，你可以完成句子等等。它感觉像是一个非常通用的模型，它是多语言的，你几乎可以完成任何句子。我觉得强化学习需要某种类似的东西，你不是完全从零开始训练。
Like when you start training, let's say a robot arm or something, you would start with a model that kind of understands like, oh, if I swing this arm really fast, that's dangerous. You know, like just that concept could just be there on the first epoch. And it would just understand that, like, high acceleration is dangerous. Now, of course, you could hard code that, right? And that's what people do. But, like, that's just one example.
就像当你开始训练，比如说一个机械臂时，你会从一个模型开始，它理解，哦，如果我挥动这个手臂太快，那是危险的。你知道，仅仅那个概念就可以在第一个 epoch 就存在。它会理解，高加速度是危险的。当然，你可以硬编码，对吧？人们就是这么做的。但是，这只是一个例子。
It'd be cool if there was a model that was, like, just, like, at a high level understood, like, smoothness and efficiency and these things. And I think the community is still, you know, here we are like almost 10 years later, the community is still kind of like marching towards that. And this is kind of the latest paper. This one is a really big advancement in this direction. So it's a very simple to read paper. They paid for a domain name for the research paper, which I think is a really clever way to spend $10 and really boost yourself if you're a PhD student.
如果有一个模型，在高层理解平滑度和效率这些东西，那会很酷。我认为社区仍然，你看，快 10 年过去了，社区仍然在朝着那个方向前进。这就是最新的论文。这是一个非常大的进步。所以这是一篇读起来非常简单的论文。他们为研究论文付钱买了一个域名，我认为这是一个非常聪明的花 10 美元的方式，如果你是博士生，这真的能提升你自己。
I mean, this is like a nice hack, but you could see kind of some cool examples. They have nice videos. The paper is like relatively easy to read. You know, if you get stuck, there's citations, obviously, so you can kind of go back. But without like spending a whole bunch of time on this, you know, they basically are able to build world models.
我的意思是，这是一个很好的技巧，但你可以看到一些很酷的例子。他们有很棒的视频。论文读起来相对容易。你知道，如果你卡住了，显然有引用，所以你可以回溯。但不用花太多时间在这上面，你知道，他们基本上能够构建世界模型。
So I'll explain just, I think we talked about this in the RL podcast, but like, you know, world models are really tough because most of the time you're just predicting like the next word or you're predicting like, should I show this ad to somebody is like, there's always like relatively like small space, like a yes, no question. Um, but in this this case like you have to predict then what the future of the world looks like. And so there's like a
所以我来解释一下，我想我们在 RL 播客里聊过这个，但你知道，世界模型真的很难，因为大多数时候你只是在预测下一个词，或者你在预测，我应该给某人展示这个广告吗？这总是一个相对较小的空间，比如一个是非题。嗯，但在这种情况下，你必须预测世界的未来是什么样的。所以有很多东西你必须同时预测，这使得它极其困难。一篇非常有趣的论文叫 Dreamer，然后 Dreamer v2、v3 都出来了，而这
lot of things you have to predict all at the same time and that makes it extremely difficult. A really interesting paper called Dreamer and then Dreamer v2 v3 have come out and this And this is just an incremental improvement on Dreamer, but these increments are getting big. And this one in particular, I think really is inspiring. And so give it a read, if you're into this area or if you want to be into this area, it's a good way to get started.
只是对 Dreamer 的增量改进，但这些增量正在变大。特别是这一篇，我认为真的很鼓舞人心。所以读一读吧，如果你对这个领域感兴趣，或者如果你想进入这个领域，这是一个很好的入门方式。
And I'm really excited to see where all it goes. So the world model isn't something I guess I hadn't really thought that much about it, but the world model isn't something that a programmer writes. It's something that is like learned. So the system itself is trying to. the system itself is trying to, like I guess that's the part that always like leaves like model in this always is a bit confusing to me. So it's not a set of physics equations,
我真的很兴奋看到它会走向何方。所以世界模型不是我想象中程序员写的东西。它是学习出来的。所以系统本身正在尝试……系统本身正在尝试，就像……我想这就是那个总是让我觉得“模型”这个词在这里有点困惑的地方。所以它不是一组物理方程，
it's sort of like in the same way of everything else as a way of updating the values in the tensors or whatever from frame to frame of the planning in a way that reflects the progression of the tensors or whatever from frame to frame of the planning in a way that reflects the progression of the world. Yeah, exactly. So like take like chess, for example. So like chess, you could argue doesn't need a world model because the game is so easy
它有点像其他所有东西一样，是一种更新张量值的方式，从规划的每一帧到下一帧，以一种反映世界演变的方式。是的，完全正确。所以拿国际象棋举例。所以国际象棋，你可以说不需要世界模型，因为游戏太容易
to simulate, right? But you still have this problem where if you don't have a world model, then how do you rewind time? Now in the case of chess, you know, maybe you store the state of the board or you store the moves you made and they're all reversible, right? But like for a lot of games, it's pretty difficult to be able to rewind time and ask like what if questions right so if you want to ask me a thousand what if questions you have to be able to ask the first one and rewind back and ask the second one sure sure yeah and so it look at like mario like we talked about mario earlier if you wanted to do reinforce learning algorithm to play mario. and learning algorithm to play Mario, you know, and you want to do counterfactuals. So you want to plan. You're going to have to like say,
模拟了，对吧？但你仍然面临这个问题，如果你没有世界模型，那么你如何倒带时间？在国际象棋的情况下，你知道，也许你存储棋盘的状态，或者你存储你走的棋步，它们都是可逆的，对吧？但对于很多游戏，要能够倒带时间并询问“如果……会怎样”的问题是非常困难的，对吧？所以如果你想问我一千个“如果……会怎样”的问题，你必须能够问第一个，然后倒带回来问第二个。当然，当然。是的，所以看看马里奥，就像我们之前聊的马里奥，如果你想做一个强化学习算法来玩马里奥，
okay, what happens if I jump? Oh, if I jump, I hit the flaming rotating thing and I die. So let's go back and try something else. Well, how do you do that? Go back. Now, like you have to implement safe states and it could be really expensive. It's not really practical.
并且你想做反事实推理。所以你想规划。你必须说，
If you have a world model, then your input is just like an input to a neural net, it's just like a vector, and they're super easy to store, to retrieve and everything. So even for like chess and Mario and these games, a world model makes planning practical. Got it, got it. Yeah, and so that's why you you could have
好吧，如果我跳会发生什么？哦，如果我跳，我会撞到那个旋转的火焰东西然后死掉。所以让我们回去尝试别的东西。好吧，你怎么做？回去。现在，你必须实现保存状态，这可能非常昂贵。这并不实用。
physics. You know physics is extremely lightweight but but most like simulators, emulators are just too heavy weight so you'd build a world model regardless. All right. You said the paper was easy to read so I'm gonna take it as a challenge and I will attempt to read the paper and see if that's true. Yeah. I'm debating whether or not to tell this story, but the primary author was a visiting lecturer at a company I worked at.
如果你有一个世界模型，那么你的输入只是神经网络的一个输入，它只是一个向量，它们非常容易存储、检索等等。所以即使对于国际象棋、马里奥和这些游戏，世界模型也让规划变得实用。明白了，明白了。是的，这就是为什么你可以有
And he's super nice, really nice guy. His name is Xiaolong Wang. But his auto-generated email was XLWang. And I thought that he picked that email. So I was like, oh, your email's really funny. I thought it was clever and I thought it was very funny. And he's like, I don't know what you're talking about. Uh-oh, all right, all right.
物理。你知道物理是非常轻量级的，但大多数模拟器、模拟器太重了，所以无论如何你都会构建一个世界模型。好吧。你说这篇论文读起来很容易，所以我把它当作一个挑战，我会尝试读一下这篇论文，看看是不是真的。是的。我在纠结要不要讲这个故事，但主要作者是我工作过的一家公司的客座讲师。
No, no, no, no. Stop it. Stop it. I was like, nevermind, I'm an idiot. But if you're out there, I didn't mean that as like, insult or anything. I thought it was hilarious. It's still very funny. But, you know, these things happen.
他超级好，非常好的人。他的名字叫王晓龙（Xiaolong Wang）。但他的自动生成的电子邮件是 XLWang。我以为是他自己选的那个邮箱。所以我说，哦，你的邮箱真有趣。我觉得很聪明，而且我觉得非常有趣。他说，我不知道你在说什么。呃哦，好吧，好吧。
We're in a hard pivot. Clever code is probably... What kind of pivot? Clever... Jason, you're in a mood today, man. All right. Clever code is probably the worst code you could write. This is on a blog code you could write.
不，不，不，不。停下。停下。我说，算了，我是个白痴。但如果你在听，我不是那个意思，不是侮辱什么的。我觉得这太搞笑了。这仍然非常有趣。但是，你知道，这些事情会发生。
This is on a blog, engineers codex. Link will be in the show notes, like always. But here, one of those things where they're making a great point, they have some well-sourced comics that are applicable to this. But just talking about their personal experience that you show up, you're a new coder and you're like, I'm going to be so smart.
我们来个大转弯。聪明的代码可能是……什么样的转弯？聪明的……Jason，你今天心情不错啊，伙计。好吧。聪明的代码可能是你能写出的最糟糕的代码。这是在一个博客上，工程师法典（Engineers Codex）。链接会像往常一样放在节目说明里。但这里，他们指出了一个很好的观点，他们有一些适用的、来源可靠的漫画。但只是谈论他们的个人经历，你刚入行，你是个新程序员，你会想，我要变得非常聪明。
I'm going to write the fewest characters, the fewest taps on my keyboard. And then as you, I don't know, I don't want to say become an old programmer, but now it's how do I write literally the dumbest thing that will get the job done? And it's okay if it takes a lot of I mean within reason you ever see those kind of like running jokes on you know X or reddit or something where people are like how to find prime numbers one to a hundred and they put like a giant if statement and yeah like all the all the prime numbers between one and a hundred hard-coded as if statements or something. Okay. Yeah. I mean, there's a balance there. Um, but yeah, for sure, you know, these like very terse, very compact things.
我要写最少的字符，键盘敲击次数最少。然后当你，我不想说成为老程序员，但现在是如何写出能完成工作的最笨的代码？如果它需要很多……我是说在合理范围内。你有没有见过那种在 X 或 Reddit 上流传的笑话，人们说如何找到 1 到 100 的质数，然后他们写了一个巨大的 if 语句，是的，就像把 1 到 100 之间的所有质数硬编码为 if 语句之类的。好吧。我是说，这中间有个平衡。嗯，但确实，你知道，这些非常简洁、非常紧凑的东西。
And we've talked about this, you know, on the show, it's not going to belabor it, but more than just observing that that that's bad. They were sort of, which isn't always true. Sometimes you find something that's bad and it doesn't yield to the good thing. Um, it just says this thing is bad and you got to move somewhere else in the design space and try again. But in this case, they were kind of pointing out, which I think is a good call, that actually here doing the almost the opposite thing of the clever code and writing that is almost always a really good decision and harder than you think. And so writing code that works and is effective
我们聊过这个，你知道，在节目里，我就不赘述了，但不仅仅是观察到那是坏的。他们有点，我认为这是一个很好的呼吁，实际上在这里做几乎与聪明代码相反的事情，写那种代码几乎总是一个非常好的决定，而且比你想象的要难。所以写出能工作、有效
than you think. And so writing code that works and is effective and is understandable by the audience, and most importantly, you know, like understandable by you in five years when you've forgotten everything about that code. There's certain pieces of code base that I just like I dread going into because I just know that yes, it works, but it wasn't done with a clarity of thought. And, uh, sometimes that's because you're trying to grow it organically. Sometimes you didn't really know what you were doing until you got done with it. But the places where you knew what you were going and you got in and got done, and you followed, you know, like your, your guiding principles about how the code should be, you know, modularized and segmented and, you know, all that kind of stuff are, are much less problematic to go into and it's one of
且受众能理解的代码，最重要的是，你知道，五年后当你忘记了关于那段代码的一切时，你自己也能理解。有些代码库我就是害怕进去，因为我知道，是的，它能工作，但它不是带着清晰的思路完成的。而且，有时那是因为你试图有机地增长它。有时在你完成它之前，你并不知道自己在做什么。但那些你知道自己在做什么，进去并完成它，并且遵循，你知道，你关于代码应该如何模块化、分段等等的指导原则的地方，进去之后问题要少得多，而且这是
Those things where again, it's it's sort of like going the opposite of that, right? So writing really compact lines putting everything in one big function, you know makes it seem like wow This is really good code like look how dense it is But again, like if you think about that was like those places where I know in the code base There's like one really big function that just does a bunch of stuff. It's like, Oh, no one wants to touch it, but you occasionally have to go in and add yet more and it's like, yeah, this really needs to get broken apart and everyone just kind of dodges doing it because unpacking it is just such a heavy burden.
那些事情之一，再次强调，它有点像反其道而行之，对吧？所以写非常紧凑的行，把所有东西放在一个大函数里，你知道，让人觉得“哇，这真是好代码，看它多密集”。但同样，如果你想想那些我知道在代码库里有那种只有一个非常大的函数，它只是做了很多事情。就像，哦，没人想碰它，但你偶尔必须进去添加更多东西，就像，是的，这真的需要被拆分，每个人都只是回避去做，因为拆解它是一个沉重的负担。
Yeah, totally. I mean, I'm thinking about, I saw this code one time where it used like templates to auto-generate classes. It's like you needed like a float handler and an int handler and a foo handler and a bar handler. It's like, oh, I'm gonna make a template and then I'm just gonna have like instantiate this template like 20 times for these 20 different handlers and yeah just like then you know someone like control F tries to find the function and they can't because it's auto generated and everything yeah it's
是的，完全同意。我是说，我想到我曾经见过的一段代码，它使用模板来自动生成类。就像你需要一个浮点处理器、一个整数处理器、一个 foo 处理器和一个 bar 处理器。就像，哦，我要做一个模板，然后我只要实例化这个模板 20 次，针对这 20 个不同的处理器，然后，你知道，有人像 Ctrl+F 试图找到那个函数，但找不到，因为它是自动生成的，等等。是的，这真是……
like yeah you you were clever and you saved you know maybe like three hours of development time but you added like a thousand hours of debugging time. Yeah, that's cool. Yeah. I think this is like along with memory management and, and, and, uh, you know, instrumentation, this is really what separates, I think the wheat from the chaff. So, I think the wheat from the chaff. So, yeah, this is cool. I'm gonna give it a read. My second news is this open source text to speech model called DIA.
没错，你确实很聪明，可能节省了三个小时的开发时间，但却增加了上千小时的调试时间。嗯，这很酷。是的。我认为这和内存管理、工具化一样，是真正区分“麦子与糠”（优劣）的关键。所以，这很酷。我打算读一读。我的第二个新闻是这个名为DIA的开源文本转语音模型。
So the article says DIA has arrived to challenge 11 labs, OpenAI and more. Patrick, have you ever used text to speech like recently in the past few years? text to speech like recently in the past few years? No, other than like an AI response service that's like re-saying words that I said, I've not attempted to like have something read to me. It is remarkably good.
文章说DIA的出现是为了挑战11labs、OpenAI等公司。Patrick，你最近几年用过文本转语音吗？除了像AI响应服务那样重复我说的话之外，我没有尝试过让什么东西读给我听。它确实非常出色。
So like you can now put emotes. So like in parentheses you can put laughs and like the speech, the character will like the speech, it will actually laugh like and then continue talking it's supernatural it's amazing and 11 labs in particular has this really interesting thing which I highly suggest people play around with it's totally free until you hit a certain usage. But you can have it create a voice just by describing the voice. So you could say like an ogre that's terrorizing a village
你可以加入表情符号。比如在括号里写上“笑”，角色在说话时真的会笑出来，然后继续说话，这太自然了，太神奇了。11labs有一个特别有趣的功能，我强烈建议大家去玩玩，在达到一定使用量之前是完全免费的。你可以通过描述来创建一个声音，比如你可以说“一个正在恐吓村庄的食人魔”。
or like a woman, a soccer announcer or something. And it will like create that voice and then you can say whatever you want in the voice. So that's pretty mind blowing. And I feel like text to speech is one of these things that like kind of needs to be open source because you kind of need to on the fly, you know, generate a lot of speech. You know, I'm imagining like my house, like if I wanted to have my own Alexa.
或者像一个女足球解说员之类的。它会创建那个声音，然后你可以让它用那个声音说任何你想说的话。这真的很令人震撼。我觉得文本转语音是那种需要开源的东西，因为你需要随时随地生成大量的语音。我在想，比如在家里，如果我想拥有自己的Alexa。
Well, like Alexa kind of needs to be able to say anything at any time, and it needs to be kind of real time. And so I guess you could do it with some kind of API charging or something, but for me, it kind of feels like something that should just run locally and be relatively quick. And so Dia is open source and they claim to be comparable with you know all these other
Alexa需要能够随时随地说话，而且需要是实时的。我想你可以通过某种API计费来实现，但对我来说，这感觉应该是在本地运行且速度较快的东西。Dia是开源的，他们声称可以与所有其他领先系统相媲美。
kind of you know leading systems. So and the models also aren't that big like people are used to seeing GPT or even the text to image models that are really big and they barely fit on your GPU. You have to jump through all sorts of hoops. But because this is text to audio, the models comfortably fit on commodity hardware. And so I haven't tried this one in particular, but I'm going to try it later today. And I think we're very close to getting to the point where like, you know, if you ever just needed something
而且这些模型并不大，不像大家习惯看到的GPT，甚至是那些非常大、几乎塞不进GPU的文本转图像模型。你必须费尽周折。但因为这是文本转音频，模型可以轻松地在普通硬件上运行。我还没试过这个，但我今天晚些时候会试试。我认为我们已经非常接近那种程度了，如果你需要让某样东西说点什么，你随时都可以做到，这已经完全商品化了，而且效果很好。它如何处理复制名人声音的问题？
to say something that you could just do it and it's just, it's a total commodity and works great. How does it handle like, not getting a problem with copying celebrity voices. So they have that with image generation or video generation, someone was pointing out, if you say words that are like copyright, like I want a picture of Mickey Mouse, right?
他们在图像生成或视频生成方面有这个问题，有人指出，如果你说出受版权保护的词，比如“我想要一张米老鼠的照片”，对吧？
But if you say I want a famous animated cartoon rodent, right, like there's only one of those in the training data. And so it'll, you know, sort of like, there's all these kind of loopholes and workarounds. If you want like a specific person to, you know, can you achieve it by describing them? Or do they also put the same kind of censoring safeguards in to try to catch it late that, oh, no, no, no, this sounds too close to a known celebrity. Like we can't do this voice. Yeah. I mean, what I know is I went on
但如果你说“我想要一只著名的动画卡通啮齿动物”，训练数据中只有一个这样的对象。所以会有各种漏洞和变通方法。如果你想要特定的人，你能通过描述来实现吗？或者他们是否也设置了同样的审查机制来捕捉，比如“不，这听起来太像某个名人了，我们不能做这个声音”。我知道的是，我去了
11 labs and I said basically it was my friend's birthday and I wanted the Unreal Tournament announcer. Remember this game Unreal Tournament? Yeah. I wanted the Unreal Tournament announcer to wish him a happy birthday. So I went on 11 labs and I said give me the Unreal Tournament announcer voice and yeah as you said it
11labs，当时是我朋友的生日，我想要《虚幻竞技场》解说员的声音。还记得《虚幻竞技场》这个游戏吗？是的。我想要《虚幻竞技场》的解说员祝他生日快乐。所以我去了11labs，说给我《虚幻竞技场》解说员的声音，然后正如你所说，它
came back and said you know I can't do copyrighted stuff etc. And yeah, as you said, it came back and said, I can't do copyrighted stuff, et cetera. And then I tried a few different things. I tried give me a video game announcer voice from a first person shooter video game. I tried to be kind of generic, and it caught me every time. So what I ended up doing is I ended up having to use a different tool. It turns out there's a website you can go to or someone else has an Unreal Tournament voice.
回复说“我不能做受版权保护的内容”等等。然后我尝试了其他几种方法。我试着说“给我一个第一人称射击游戏的解说员声音”。我试图让它变得通用，但每次都被拦截了。所以我最后不得不使用另一个工具。事实证明，有一个网站，或者其他人有《虚幻竞技场》的声音。
Uncensored. Yeah. Well, that's what I was going to ask because you could just do like, give it a voice sample. And even if you don't do like voice cloning, say, can you describe this voice for me in excruciating detail and then have it, you know, give all of the idiosyncrasies of the pronunciations and all of the, you know, timber and tone and all of that and then feed that in and say like, okay, now I want these words in this description. But like you said, I, there feels like there's probably still some other mechanism where they work hard to sensor, which is always crazy because it has nothing to do with the actual quality of the outputs.
未审查版的。是的，这就是我要问的，因为你可以给它一个语音样本。即使你不做语音克隆，你说“你能极其详细地描述这个声音，然后给出所有发音的特质、音色和语调，然后输入进去，说‘现在我想要这些词用这种描述来说’”？但正如你所说，感觉可能还有其他机制在努力进行审查，这总是很疯狂，因为它与输出的实际质量无关。
It's strictly just for censoring purposes. Yeah. I mean, I doubt that 11 Labs sensors or even OpenAI, I don't think they actually go back and look at your picture and then say, whoops, we messed up or do that. So they definitely do for images because this happened I was trying out a new chat GPT image generator which is really good by the way and does a different approach than a lot of the other diffusion stuff and so I had it generate something which I don't know a very famous style of puppets from a picture of my family.
这纯粹是为了审查目的。是的，我怀疑11labs或OpenAI是否真的会回头看你的图片，然后说“哎呀，我们搞砸了”。但他们肯定会对图像进行审查，因为我当时正在尝试一个新的ChatGPT图像生成器，顺便说一下，它非常好，而且采用了与许多其他扩散模型不同的方法。所以我让它生成了一些东西，我不知道，一种非常著名的木偶风格，基于我家庭的照片。
And it got like, you know, if you've seen, if you've tried the chat GPT-1, because it's not, it goes top to bottom. So it starts rendering, you know, top to bottom. And it got half the image like, whoa, this is really good. Like it perfectly kept the background, used a famous female pig, a famous male frog, and you know, a famous drummer.
它生成了一半，如果你试过ChatGPT的那个，它是从上到下渲染的。它渲染了一半，我心想“哇，这太棒了”。它完美地保留了背景，使用了著名的猪小姐、著名的青蛙和著名的鼓手。
So like- We're going to lose our sponsor. No, no. Our Patreons are bailing on us. So it got happened. I was like, this is great. I wish I had taken a screen shot. It was like, this is killer, this is amazing. Then as soon as it got part of the way through, it realized it was
所以……我们要失去赞助商了。不，不。我们的Patreon支持者要抛弃我们了。它渲染到一半时，我心想“这太棒了，真希望我截了图”。它简直太绝了，太神奇了。然后当它渲染到一半时，它意识到它正在
generating copyrighted content and then it like it bounced it was like oh I can't do that. Wow that is wild I don't know if 11 Labs does that to be honest I would have said emphatically no but now I'm not so sure. They do support voice cloning I feel like you could probably put like a low pass filter and some other tricks to like you know make a voice not get picked up you know like to circumvent all the fingerprinting. But this DL1 also supports a voice cloning and it's open source so I think in this case is really nothing
生成受版权保护的内容，然后它就跳开了，说“哦，我不能那样做”。哇，这太疯狂了。老实说，我不知道11labs是否会那样做，我本来会断然否认，但现在我不确定了。他们确实支持语音克隆，我觉得你可能可以通过低通滤波器和其他技巧来让声音不被识别，从而绕过所有指纹识别。但这个Dia也支持语音克隆，而且是开源的，所以我认为在这种情况下，真的没有什么
preventing you from getting a bunch of Unreal Tournament voice samples, running them through Dia, generating a voice and then having an Unreal Tournament announcer say whatever it wants to your friends. Yeah, so I think that that's a really interesting idea though, the whole post-hoc censorship. Maybe you could take a screenshot quickly or who knows. But yeah, I think that there's another debate around the open source versus closed source situation.
能阻止你获取一堆《虚幻竞技场》的语音样本，通过Dia运行，生成一个声音，然后让《虚幻竞技场》的解说员对你的朋友说任何话。是的，所以我认为这是一个非常有趣的想法，关于事后审查。也许你可以快速截图，或者谁知道呢。但我觉得围绕开源与闭源的情况还有另一场辩论。
I mean, these open source models are getting really good and it might come to the point where, like there's a lot of things like this, like compilers are an example. So, way back in the day, Patrick and I used this compiler called Green Hills. Patrick, I don't know if you remember the Green Hills compiler. Yes.
我的意思是，这些开源模型正变得越来越好，可能会达到这样一个地步，就像编译器是一个例子。很久以前，Patrick和我用过一个叫Green Hills的编译器。Patrick，不知道你还记不记得Green Hills编译器。记得。
Yeah. Are you going to pay up? Yep. That's an example where like you could get GCC open source and for 90% of people it's good enough, but like you need this Green Hills and honestly, this is out of my area of expertise, so I wouldn't even really know what's going on there. But, but like, suffice it to say our company bought the Green Hills compiler and so it might get to the point where like Dia and other open source models are good for like 95% of us and you know you just use OpenAI or one of
是的。你要付钱吗？是的。这是一个例子，你可以获得开源的GCC，对于90%的人来说已经足够好了，但你需要这个Green Hills。老实说，这超出了我的专业领域，所以我甚至不知道那里发生了什么。但足以说明，我们公司购买了Green Hills编译器，所以可能会达到这样一个地步：Dia和其他开源模型对我们95%的人来说已经足够好了，而当你需要那5%的优势时，你才会去使用OpenAI或其他模型。
these other models when that 5% makes it kind of worth it. So that might be where we end up with all of these. Yeah, I saw, not, we're mixing the news, we can move on, but I saw OpenAI was saying they're gonna release an actual open source model soon. So yeah, I'm curious where the money will be made. Inference, test time compute, is it gonna be the models? Like, I mean, I think like you said, yeah, it's compute, is it going to be the models? Like, I mean, I think like, yeah, it's going to be all over the place.
所以这可能是我们最终的归宿。是的，我看到，我们别混淆新闻了，我们可以继续，但我看到OpenAI说他们很快会发布一个真正的开源模型。所以我很好奇钱会从哪里赚。推理、测试时计算，会是模型本身吗？我的意思是，就像你说的，这会是全方位的。
I'm fascinated by running it at home, but it feels like, I don't know. I see people buying rigs and doing like video generation. Um, but then it's so hard to keep up with. So people did that when they were doing like cryptocurrency mining and they get the latest miners and, you know, and for some people that paid off, I'm not sure there's a payoff here in the same way. If you go out and buy hardware to do all this stuff at home.
我对在家里运行它很着迷，但我不知道。我看到人们购买设备进行视频生成。但跟上这些太难了。人们在做加密货币挖矿时也这样做，他们购买最新的矿机，对有些人来说确实有回报，我不确定在这里以同样的方式是否有回报。如果你出去买硬件在家里做所有这些事情。
Yeah. If you're a business, I feel like renting it is still better. Even if you're choosing to be on an open source stack for, for whatever reason, like renting at least the hardware, um hardware and then using the models and stuff, because it moves so much. You can end up being in the wrong place and sort of behind and really wanting something different than what you have. Yeah, totally agree.
是的。如果你是一家企业，我觉得租用仍然更好。即使你出于某种原因选择使用开源技术栈，至少租用硬件，然后使用模型，因为技术发展太快了。你最终可能会处于错误的位置，落后于人，并且非常想要与你所拥有的不同的东西。完全同意。
I see no point in paying, like buying this stuff outright when you can rent even an EC2 instance from Amazon and it's only like 90 cents an hour, you'd have to run it for so many hours to justify, you know, buying it yourself and the electricity and the depreciation and all that. All right. Time for book of the show. Patrick, what is your book of the show? All right. So mine's a bit out of left field and by no means, you know, am I a exercising person?
我觉得直接购买这些东西毫无意义，因为你可以从亚马逊租用EC2实例，每小时只需90美分。你需要运行很多小时才能证明购买它、电费和折旧等是合理的。好了，节目推荐书的时间到了。Patrick，你推荐什么书？好的，我的书有点出人意料，而且我绝不是一个爱运动的人。
I've been trying to be diligent about the amount of exercise I do over the next last few years and going to the gym. Well, I have gym equipment, you know, just in my, in my, one of my rooms that I, you know, I just heavy objects around for a few minutes is what I say when I'm going to go do it. I'm going to go move heavy objects up and down for no reason. But, but trying not to, to, you know, have the myriad of health problems that can creep up from sitting in a chair in front of your computer all day.
过去几年我一直努力坚持锻炼，去健身房。好吧，我确实在我的一个房间里有健身器材，我只是说“我要去搬几分钟重物”。我只是去上下搬动重物，没有任何理由。但努力不让自己因为整天坐在电脑前而出现各种健康问题。
Yeah. And there's a guy on YouTube, Jeff Nippard, who does sort of, I don't know, mostly lie harder content about in the gym. He's very large guy, like in terms of muscle mass, I am not that way at all. Um, but you know, he has some like sort of, let's take a science backed approach rather than just like, you know, go until you puke or, you know, if you're, if you're not, if you're not hurting, you're not doing it hard enough.
是的。YouTube上有一个叫Jeff Nippard的人，他做的是关于健身的科学内容。他是一个非常强壮的人，就肌肉量而言，我完全不是那样。但他有一些科学支持的方法，而不是仅仅“练到呕吐”或者“如果不疼就练得不够狠”。
Um, and so generally good, good. There's several good YouTube videos, I think for, for watching this stuff. And although these guys may spend, you know, 30 minutes or an hour in a gym every single day, you know, he will also point out there's ways to spend, you know, sort of 30 minutes once or twice a week, if you're really efficient, if you combine them in certain ways. Anyways, he put together an actual, you know, physical book.
总的来说，有很多好的YouTube视频。虽然这些人可能每天在健身房花30分钟到一个小时，但他也会指出，如果你效率很高，每周花一两次30分钟也是有办法的。无论如何，他整理了一本真正的实体书。
He had exercise routines and stuff before, and it's always a bit sketchy for me whenever I hear YouTubers, you know, like, oh, buy my ebook, buy my PDF, buy my, I don't know. I'm trying to think if I've ever done that, if maybe once or twice. Anyways, he had a book and it was on Amazon, like an actual hardback book. It was, you know, reasonably affordable called The Muscle Ladder. The analogy is kind of weird, but you know, talks about principles that are sort of the sides of the ladder and then rungs on the ladder, but also includes a
他之前就有锻炼计划，每当我听到YouTuber说“买我的电子书，买我的PDF”时，我总是觉得有点不靠谱。我在想我是否曾经这样做过，也许一两次吧。无论如何，他有一本书在亚马逊上，是一本真正的精装书。价格合理，叫《肌肉阶梯》（The Muscle Ladder）。这个比喻有点奇怪，但它谈论了一些原则，就像阶梯的两侧和横档，但也包括了
bunch of, you know, sort of workout routines and also pictures, which is very useful for me because sometimes you just read this like, Oh, you're supposed to, I'm, again, it's not my background, a Romanian deadlift or a sumo squat or anything. I'm like, I don't, what is, what is that? Romanian deadlift or a sumo squat or anything. I don't know. What is, what is that? Like I vaguely know what the word squat means. Um, but so then you're like going on YouTube, trying to find a video to watch. And then the person's like, hi, I'm so and so subscribe and like, and you know, five minutes, you're like, Oh, just show me the, like, what is the thing?
一堆锻炼计划和图片，这对我也很有用，因为有时你读到“罗马尼亚硬拉”或“相扑深蹲”之类的，我会想“那是什么？”。我隐约知道深蹲是什么意思。但你得去YouTube找视频看。然后那个人说“嗨，我是某某，请订阅点赞”，五分钟后你心想“直接给我看动作是什么”。
But he has nice pictures for each of the exercises. So just, I find a very useful book as I'm trying to, you know, find a sort of routine that works for me. So people will be like, the weird pic, Patrick, go back to the sci-fi. Yeah, you're probably right. Probably should go back to the sci-fi fantasy pics. But it's a book that I have actually been reading.
但他为每个练习都配了精美的图片。所以我发现这是一本非常有用的书，因为我正在努力寻找适合我的日常锻炼。所以人们会说“奇怪的选择，Patrick，回去看科幻小说吧”。是的，你可能是对的。可能应该回去看科幻奇幻小说。但这确实是我一直在读的书。
So I guess it's a full transparency. How have you changed your routine? Like, are you lifting heavier things? Are you in the heavy lifting room longer or what? Uh, I think it's finding like what, what exercises kind of pair well together isn't obvious to me. So I'll tend to just go and do whatever exercise I know. Um, but there are often when you read these a lot of variations on the exercise
所以我想这是完全透明的。你如何改变你的日常锻炼？比如，你举得更重了吗？你在重力训练室待的时间更长了吗？我觉得找到哪些练习搭配在一起效果更好对我来说并不明显。所以我倾向于只做我熟悉的练习。
to target slightly different parts of like for me it's like I'm going to squat why am I going to squat well I want stronger legs it's like okay well that's that's very crude like what part of your leg what muscle what muscle group like which, like which compound, like, uh, you know, this kind of squat targets, you know, your glutes and your hamstrings and this way, this one does in a different way. And so learning alternatives to the exercise so that after a couple of weeks of doing it one way, it's not just like keep doing that one and lifting
但当你阅读这些内容时，通常会有很多练习的变体，针对身体的不同部位。对我来说，比如“我要深蹲，为什么要深蹲？因为我想要更强壮的腿”。这太粗糙了，腿的哪个部位？哪块肌肉群？哪种复合动作？这种深蹲针对臀大肌和腿筋，而那种则以不同的方式。学习练习的替代方案，这样在坚持一种方式几周后，就不会只是重复同样的事情。
heavy, which is a philosophy. And that's kind of what I've been doing. Like just try to do the same thing over and over, but slightly heavier or slightly more, but actually also throwing in variations every few weeks where the muscle you're working in complement with that is slightly different. And so personally, that's one way that this kind of stuff has helped me. And also that keeps it from being super boring. Like for me, it's really boring to just go in there and do like exactly the same thing every time. Yeah that makes sense. That is super cool. My book this show needs a little bit of intro because this is one of these ones where like this could easily
举重是一种哲学。这就是我一直在做的。尝试一遍又一遍地做同样的事情，但稍微重一点或多一点，但实际上每隔几周也会加入一些变体，这样你锻炼的肌肉会有所不同。对我个人而言，这是这种书帮助我的方式。而且这也能防止它变得超级无聊。对我来说，每次去健身房做完全一样的事情真的很无聊。是的，这很有道理。这太酷了。我这期的书需要一点介绍，因为这是那种很容易
degenerate into us getting all sorts of hate mail. Which we do by the way get hate mail. We don't have sponsors so no one can can can pull out of the show but we have gotten hate mail, which we do by the way, get hate mail. We don't have sponsors, so no one can, can, can pull, pull out of the show, but we have gotten hate mail before. But the reason I got to this book is because I was playing crusader Kings three. Have you ever played this game? I own this game that I bought as part of a humble bundle and I would love to play. It seems fascinating. I I'm nervous.
演变成我们收到各种仇恨邮件的书。顺便说一下，我们确实会收到仇恨邮件。我们没有赞助商，所以没有人能撤资，但我们确实收到过仇恨邮件。我读这本书的原因是因为我在玩《十字军之王3》。你玩过这个游戏吗？我拥有这个游戏，是我作为Humble Bundle的一部分买的，我很想玩。它看起来很迷人。我很紧张。
I haven't started. It's one of these games. You're like, wait a it. It seems fascinating. I'm nervous. I haven't started. It's one of these games where you're like, wait a minute, it's 4 a.m., like what just happened? Oh. And- It's paradox, right? Yeah, yeah, all these paradox games. It's actually to the point now where like,
我还没开始。这是那种游戏，你会想“等等”。它看起来很迷人。我很紧张。我还没开始。这是那种你会想“等等，现在是凌晨4点，刚才发生了什么？”的游戏。哦。而且这是Paradox的游戏，对吧？是的，所有这些Paradox游戏。现在甚至到了这种程度，
if it's a paradox game, you basically need a mod that will speed the game up because I don't know, maybe this is like conspiracy theory or whatever I feel like they purposely don't have the fastest setting on these games because they want you to spend more time because like like this game like like you could play it at a much faster speed than the fastest one I feel like and still be productive but and it's Stellaris, you know, same thing. It's like, I feel like I'm always on the fastest possible.
如果是Paradox游戏，你基本上需要一个能加速游戏的模组，因为我不知道，也许这是阴谋论什么的，我觉得他们故意不在这些游戏里设置最快速度，因为他们想让你花更多时间。因为这个游戏，我觉得你可以以比最快速度快得多的速度玩，而且仍然很有成效。Stellaris也是一样，我觉得我总是处于最快速度。
Which one of those is the best? Sorry, before we would be like, if I'm going to start, I want to play, I have a few, but I want to play one of these paradox games. So is the easiest. Yeah, what I would say is you should play based on the theme. Like, do you want to be a medieval king
哪一个是最好的？抱歉，在开始之前，如果我要玩，我想玩其中一个Paradox游戏。所以哪个最简单？是的，我会说你应该根据主题来玩。你想成为中世纪的国王
or do you want to be like a space empire? That's really the decision you have to make. Oh, so Stellaris, I basically play it, and Crusader Kings, I play both of these games as if they're turn-based, where like, I want the speed to be infinitely fast until something interesting happens, and then I want to pause, right? And so what I really want is a turn-based game and not like these like real-time games. But the gameplay and everything, the story and the theme and the setting is so good that like it makes up for what I think is actually not that great gameplay. But the story is amazing. And so I was playing Crusader Kings,
还是想成为太空帝国？这才是你必须做的决定。哦，所以Stellaris，我基本上是玩它，而《十字军之王》，我玩这两个游戏就像它们是回合制的一样，我希望速度无限快，直到发生有趣的事情，然后我暂停，对吧？所以我真正想要的是回合制游戏，而不是这种实时游戏。但游戏玩法、故事、主题和背景都太好了，以至于弥补了我认为其实并不那么好的游戏玩法。但故事太棒了。所以我当时在玩《十字军之王》，
very emergent, love it. And I just got to thinking about war and, and going to war and like, why do people go to war and like, why, why do people fight each other? And, uh, you know, cause Crusader Kings is a very deep game. It's not just like, Oh, I'm just going to get to the point where my army is bigger than the army next to me and then just kill them. Like you would in like Starcraft or something. In Crusader Kings, there's like all this diplomacy and all this stuff, right? And so I started thinking about like, why do these people even go to war?
非常具有突发性，我很喜欢。我开始思考战争，去打仗，为什么人们会去打仗，为什么人们会互相争斗？而且，《十字军之王》是一个非常深度的游戏。它不仅仅是“我要让我的军队比隔壁的军队大，然后杀了他们”，就像你在《星际争霸》里做的那样。在《十字军之王》里，有各种外交和各种事情，对吧？所以我开始思考，为什么这些人甚至会去打仗？
Like why would these people fight for you? And so that let me down this rabbit hole where I ended up reading this book called The Metaphysics of War. And they talk about basically like historically how people were motivated to go into battle. Like imagine if there's a battle and you have a hundred people and the enemy has a thousand people and you're probably going to die. How do people actually fight those battles? People did obviously run away and everything too. This book talks about how in the medieval times, around the times of Crusader Kings, you know, they would talk to these Crusaders and say, look, if you die in battle, it's actually even better than
为什么这些人会为你而战？这让我陷入了一个兔子洞，我最终读了一本叫《战争的形而上学》（The Metaphysics of War）的书。他们谈论的是历史上人们是如何被激励去参加战斗的。想象一下，如果有一场战斗，你有100人，敌人有1000人，你很可能会死。人们实际上是如何进行那些战斗的？人们显然也会逃跑。这本书谈到了在中世纪，在《十字军之王》的时代，他们会告诉那些十字军，看，如果你在战斗中死去，这甚至比
winning because you get this like special place in the afterlife. Whereas if you had won the battle and then just, you know, died of old age, you actually, it's not, you don't, you end up in like a different part of paradise or whatever. Now all of this, like we're not making any, this is what I was worried about, the hate mail. We're not making any moral claims. We're not saying that's right or wrong or anything.
获胜更好，因为你在来世会有一个特殊的位置。而如果你赢了战斗，然后只是死于自然衰老，你最终会去天堂的不同部分。现在，我们没有做出任何道德主张。我们不是说那是对还是错。
But just understanding what the mentality was at the time and everything was really interesting to me. So it's a pretty deep book. It's something where you have to kind of want to know answers to these kind of questions and you have to be a bit put a bit of your historian hat on. But I found it interesting. And yeah, I thought I thought it was kind of cool. I don't think I'm going to be reading any more books. I feel like I've kind of covered what I wanted to know.
但仅仅了解当时的心理状态对我来说非常有趣。所以这是一本相当深奥的书。你需要想要知道这些问题的答案，并且需要戴上历史学家的帽子。但我发现它很有趣。是的，我觉得它很酷。我想我不会再读更多的书了。我觉得我已经涵盖了我想知道的内容。
So I'm probably going to move on to a new topic, but, uh, uh, but I thought it was kind of cool and I just finished it yesterday. So. Yeah, I mean, yeah, this is a tough topic and yeah, like without making moral statements, I mean, in general, it's tough, but it doesn't seem to be going away. So war, war comes and goes. general, it's tough, but it doesn't seem to be going away. So war, war comes and goes. And yeah, I, I, I guess I consider myself lucky that I
所以我可能会转向一个新的话题，但我认为它很酷，我昨天刚读完。是的，这是一个沉重的话题，而且在不做出道德声明的情况下，总的来说，这很艰难，但它似乎并没有消失。所以战争，战争来来去去。总的来说，这很艰难，但它似乎并没有消失。所以战争，战争来来去去。是的，我想我很幸运，我
haven't had to think too much about it. Um, yeah, maybe if I played Crusader Kings, I would have thought more about it, but, uh, yeah, this is, uh, yeah. I mean, playing a video game and then being like, I think I'm going to read a book. I feel like, uh video game and then being like, I think I'm going to read a book. I feel like, uh, this might be like peak Jason here might be like the nerdiest thing I've ever done.
不需要考虑太多。嗯，也许如果我玩《十字军之王》，我会想得更多，但这是……我的意思是，玩一个电子游戏然后说“我想读一本书”。我觉得这可能是Jason的巅峰时刻，可能是我做过的最书呆子的事情。
But, uh, um, yeah, maybe I should play a video game like Tetris or something. All right. Time for tool of the show. All right, Patrick, what's your tool? No, it's a game. All right. Time for tool of the show. All right, Patrick, what's your tool? That's a game. All right. All right. So Jason alluded to this earlier as far as money making schemes in games, I guess. So I'll say the game,
但是，也许我应该玩像《俄罗斯方块》之类的游戏。好了，节目工具时间到了。好的，Patrick，你的工具是什么？不，那是个游戏。好了，节目工具时间到了。好的，Patrick，你的工具是什么？那是个游戏。好的。好的。Jason之前提到了游戏中的赚钱计划，我想。所以我说出那个游戏，
but then I'll give my caveat to it. So that is the Pokemon trading card game Pocket. So I've been playing this actually with my kids. I, to be clear, neither me nor my kids have spent any money on this game. It is a free to play game. But it's one of those games that has timers and you have to check back in every so often.
但我会给出我的警告。那就是《宝可梦集换式卡牌游戏Pocket》。我实际上是在和我的孩子们一起玩这个。需要说明的是，我和我的孩子们都没有在这个游戏上花钱。这是一个免费游戏。但它是那种有计时器、你需要时不时回来检查的游戏。
And there's this thing that's built in that I wanna talk about, but I had a Pokemon game for Nintendo Switch, actually, funnily enough. Although older last time now, this trading card game. And in general, I've gone through phases where I've collected cards. And then I never been super into it, but always off and on. It's intrigued me. But I've really enjoyed this game. I feel like it's reasonably generous as someone who doesn't play free to play games normally, or at least not this style. But
里面内置了一个东西，我想谈谈，但我之前确实有一个任天堂Switch上的宝可梦游戏，有趣的是。虽然那是很久以前的事了，现在是这个集换式卡牌游戏。总的来说，我经历过收集卡片的阶段。我从来没有超级沉迷，但总是断断续续。它引起了我的兴趣。但我真的很喜欢这个游戏。作为一个通常不玩免费游戏的人，或者至少不玩这种风格的人，我觉得它相当慷慨。但
you know, each day you can open, you know, a pack of cards, and then you know, you add them to your collection. And then it, you know, does all those things that feed into that certain part of your brain that's like, completing the collection, you got a new card, you got a rare card, and sort of building it up. But it has been interesting to explain to my kids, like even if all of, you know, let's say there's 50 cards to collect and you open a pack and it has five cards in it.
每天你可以打开一包卡片，然后把它们加入你的收藏。它会做所有那些能满足大脑中特定部分的事情，比如完成收藏、你得到了新卡、你得到了稀有卡，并以此建立起来。但向我的孩子们解释这一点很有趣，即使假设有50张卡片要收集，你打开一包，里面有5张卡片。
And even if all the cards were equally likely, people do this, oh, I opened 10 packs and then I have 50 cards, 50 unique cards. It's like, no, that's not how it works. If you actually look at it to get 50 unique cards where cards can occur, you know, with an even distribution, you need a lot more than 10 packs because that last card, even if they're not juicing it, even if they're not having rarity, even if they're not cheating you that last card, and you don't know which one it'll be, it'll be sort of different for everyone, but that last card,
即使所有卡片出现的概率相等，人们也会说“哦，我开了10包，我有50张卡片，50张独特的卡片”。不，不是那样工作的。如果你真的想得到50张独特的卡片，而卡片出现的概率是均匀分布的，你需要远不止10包，因为最后一张卡片，即使他们没有操纵概率，即使没有稀有度，即使他们没有欺骗你，最后一张卡片，你不知道会是哪一张，对每个人来说都不同，但最后一张卡片，
just statistically, the time to a complete deck for some people, like 10% of people, is going to be just enormously large number of pack openings they have to do. And so it really like, if you're going to play it, you have to have this attitude of like, it kind of doesn't matter. Um, but I will say they have, uh, a competitive game. The competitive game is not super strategic. You can just kind of play around. They have single player battle events that come up and you can play against the computer, which is kind of interesting.
从统计学上讲，有些人完成卡组的时间，比如10%的人，将需要打开极其大量的卡包。所以如果你要玩它，你必须有那种“无所谓”的态度。但我会说，他们有一个竞技游戏。竞技游戏不是特别有策略性。你可以随便玩玩。他们有单人战斗活动，你可以和电脑对战，这很有趣。
So it fits in that, like, you know, for a few minutes each day, you can kind of open it up and do your thing. Uh, people do the same with Duolingo and their Duolingo streaks of, you know, for a few minutes each day you can kind of open it up and do your thing. People do the same with Duolingo and their Duolingo streaks of, you know, oh I've been every day for 200 days I've been practicing this foreign language. It's not clear they actually like know the foreign language but it's just like certain thing of like doing the same thing over and over in streaks and so if you if you're interested if that at all appeals to you, they have iOS and Android.
所以它适合那种每天花几分钟打开玩玩的东西。人们对多邻国（Duolingo）也是这样，他们的多邻国连胜，每天花几分钟打开。人们对多邻国也是这样，他们的多邻国连胜，比如“哦，我已经连续200天练习这门外语了”。并不清楚他们是否真的懂这门外语，但这只是那种一遍又一遍做同样事情的连胜感。所以如果你对此感兴趣，他们有iOS和Android版本。
Again, I don't spend any money on it. If you're prone to wanting to spend money to complete something or to have the best or to have the ultra special rare cards that you see online, probably stay clear. But in general, that's not my particular vice. So I can play it and just put it down and enjoy it for the enjoyable time it is without spending money.
再说一次，我没有在上面花钱。如果你容易想要花钱来完成某事，或者想要最好的，或者想要你在网上看到的超稀有卡片，可能要避开。但总的来说，那不是我的嗜好。所以我可以玩它，然后放下，享受它带来的乐趣，而不用花钱。
That makes sense. I saw this crazy stat relate to what you were just saying. If you shuffle a deck of cards and then go through that permutation, that it's like 99 and there's like so many nines after that percent chance that nobody's seen that order before. Yeah, so if's like 99 and there's like so many nines after that percent chance that nobody's seen that order before.
这很有道理。我看到了一个与你刚才所说的相关的疯狂统计数据。如果你洗一副牌，然后遍历那个排列，有99后面跟着很多个9的百分比概率，没有人见过那个顺序。是的，所以有99后面跟着很多个9的百分比概率，没有人见过那个顺序。
Yeah. So if you like perfectly shuffle, which is actually really hard to do, if you perfectly randomly shuffle a deck of cards yet, you're probably the only person in all of time that has ever had that permutation. Yeah. It's so wild. It's just crazy. Yeah.
是的。如果你完美地洗牌，这实际上很难做到，如果你完美地随机洗牌，你很可能是历史上唯一一个拥有那个排列的人。太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。是的。
Yeah. All right. My tool to show is 5.4, which is one of these small language models. So there's, you know, everyone knows GPT and all these things. There's another category of small language models. These are basically, you know, imagine if you were making a video game and Crusader Kings, you're making Crusader Kings 27 and you, and you actually want an LLM to like generate the dialogue, right? Speaking of stuff, but you know, you would want that to run on people's computer.
是的。好了，我的节目工具是Phi-4，这是小型语言模型之一。每个人都知道GPT和所有这些东西。还有另一类小型语言模型。这些基本上是，想象一下如果你在制作一个电子游戏，比如《十字军之王27》，你想要一个LLM来生成对话，对吧？说到这个，你会希望它在人们的电脑上运行。
And so there's this question of like, you know, what can, when can we get to the point where you could deploy a desktop app with an LLM and be confident that a vast majority of your market could actually play it? It's kind of like Crisis or Cyberpunk. When these games came out, they were virtually unplayable because the graphics were just so intense. You had to have such an intense graphics card. But now you know a commodity
所以有一个问题是，我们什么时候能达到这样一个地步：你可以部署一个带有LLM的桌面应用程序，并确信绝大多数市场都能运行它？这有点像《孤岛危机》或《赛博朋克》。当这些游戏刚出来时，它们几乎无法运行，因为图形太密集了。你必须有非常强大的显卡。但现在你知道，一台普通
computer like you could buy a computer from Best Buy and you'll play cyberpunk at Ultra right. And so you know we're marching towards that. 5.4 is the five models are just extremely extremely high quality and I just can't stress this enough. I've been playing with five for a lot this week and it is right up there. You know, benchmarks are just so easy to game and, and so, so, you know, benchmarks say whatever they say. I don't even know. But, but when I use five four, I find it's comparable with all the best
电脑，你可以从百思买买一台电脑，就能以Ultra画质玩《赛博朋克》，对吧。所以我们正在朝着那个方向前进。Phi-4模型质量极高，我怎么强调都不为过。我这周一直在玩Phi-4，它非常出色。你知道，基准测试太容易作弊了，所以基准测试说什么就是什么。我甚至不知道。但当我使用Phi-4时，我发现它与所有最好的
models and, and, um, it's very small. Um, I think it's very small. I think it still requires a GPU, although there is something called Bitnet, also from Microsoft, which shrinks these models down so they can run on the CPU. And of course, you know, that, then it starts to get to the point
模型相当，而且它非常小。我认为它仍然需要GPU，尽管微软还有一种叫Bitnet的东西，可以缩小这些模型，使它们能在CPU上运行。当然，你知道，那样的话，性能就开始下降了。但正如我所说，这是一个过程，所以作为一个社区、一个行业，我们还没有达到那个地步，但我们正在接近。所以跟随并观察这些小型模型变得多么强大真的很酷。这个模型可以在你家里的GPU上舒适地运行，而且它能做所有的多模态任务。所以你可以给它音频说“转录这个”。你可以给它一张图片说“对这个进行OCR”，它实际上会秒杀几乎所有的OCR软件。比如我比较了Phi-4和Tesseract、EZ-OCR、
where it is sort of degraded performance. But as I said, you know, this is a march and so we're not there yet as a community, as an industry, but we're getting there. And so it's really cool to kind of follow along and see just how powerful some of these small models have become. So this model can run comfortably on a GPU at your home and it does all the multimodal stuff. So you can give it an audio and say transcribe this. You can give it a picture and say do OCR on this and it actually will blow away almost any OCR software. Like I compared FIFOR to Tesseract, to EZ-OCR,
TR-OCR（也是基于Transformer的），Phi-4直接秒杀了所有这些，甚至都不在一个量级上。所以能在你的电脑上运行这个真是太神奇了。所以我们现在处于这样一个地步：如果你愿意将受众限制在拥有Nvidia GPU的人群中，你就可以将LLM作为桌面软件的一部分推出，我认为这非常了不起。我认为那个气泡、那块饼，迟早会扩大到覆盖所有拥有GPU的人。迟早会扩大到覆盖所有拥有电脑的人。所以我们正在朝着那个方向前进，这很令人兴奋。
to TR-OCR which is also transformer based and 5.4 just blew away all of them like it wasn't even close so so that it's just amazing that you can just spin this up on your computer and so we're at the point now where like if if you could if you're willing to limit your audience to just people who have Nvidia GPUs, you can roll out LLMs as part of your desktop software, which I think is pretty amazing. And I think it's only a matter of time before that bubble, that pie, can grow to cover everyone with a GPU. And it only a matter of time before it can grow to cover everyone with a computer. So we're heading there and it's exciting to watch.
我很好奇，从定价成本的角度来看，是否最终会出现某种融合，比如你可以在软件中本地嵌入Phi-4，或者它只是作为你电脑上的DLL等效文件安装，各种东西都可以引用它。但同时也要有自我意识，就像你说的，OCR相当不错，但你在边缘案例中看到OCR通过这些模型产生连贯但错误的文本。如果文本太模糊，它就会假设那里可能是什么，然后吐出来。以及识别“我超出了我的能力范围，去云端问一个更大的模型”的能力，或者回来得到一种混合的方式。我还没有看到太多，人们称之为幻觉。不完全是那样，对吧。但只是对模型认为自己做得有多好的自我意识。它似乎总是假设自己做得很好。
I'm curious what, you know, from a pricing cost standpoint, if there'll end up being some blend where, yeah, like you can run one of these 5.4 locally embedded in your software or even, you know, it's just like installed as a DLL equivalent on your computer and, you know, various things can, can kind of reference it. But then also the self-awareness that like, like you said, oh, the OCR is like pretty good, but that you see examples on edge cases where the OCR via the, you know, that these models will produce coherent but wrong text. So if the text is just way too blurry, it'll just kind of assume what was
是的。你知道我会怎么做吗？如果今天让我负责这个，这些模型有一个温度参数。我会调高温度，然后运行同一个模型10到20次，得到一组答案。如果它们不一致，那么我会去求助于更大的模型。是的，这很有趣。
probably there and, you know, spit it out. And the ability to recognize like I'm beyond my abilities, like go, go to the cloud and ask a bigger model or, you know, come back and, you know, get a sort of blended, blended way. I still haven't seen much where, you know, and people call hallucinations. Not exactly that right. But just like the self-awareness of how good the model thinks it did. It just seems to always assume it's doing really good.
大概就在那里，你知道，把它吐出来。还有一种能力，就是能够识别出我超出了自己的能力范围，比如去云端请求一个更大的模型，或者回来，以一种混合的方式处理。我还没怎么见过这种情况，人们称之为幻觉，其实并不完全是那样。但这就像模型对自己表现得有多好的一种自我意识。它似乎总是认为自己做得非常好。
Yeah. You know what I would do there? You know, if I was, uh, if I was tasked with that today, you know, there's these models have a temperature parameter. And so I would crank up the temperature and then I would run the same model like 10, 20 times to get an ensemble of answers. And then if they don't agree, then I would go to the bigger model. Yeah, that's interesting.
是的。你知道如果是我，如果今天让我负责这个任务，我会怎么做吗？这些模型都有一个温度参数。所以我会调高温度，然后运行同一个模型10到20次，得到一组答案。如果它们不一致，我就会去请求更大的模型。是的，这很有趣。
Or I wonder for some of the the OCR stuff specifically, like eventually we get to a approach where you either in the model or, you know, whatever kind of project back the text, right? So like, Oh, read the text, project back the text. Like, is there agreement here or not? Yeah. You kind of like ask it to run itself backwards again, you know, and. Yeah, that's one of these things that people don't realize, but like verifying is actually
或者我想知道对于某些OCR（光学字符识别）内容，特别是我们最终是否能达到一种方法，即在模型内部，或者你知道，无论什么项目，把文本投影回去，对吧？就像，哦，读取文本，把文本投影回去。那么，这里是否存在一致性呢？是的。你就像是让它再次反向运行，你知道，而且。是的，这是人们没有意识到的事情之一，但验证实际上是
like, cause some people will say like, oh, well the model that generated the bad answer clearly can't verify, but it actually can because think about it in terms of like, like, uh, like a watering your garden. So like, if you turned on all the zones at the same time, then like it wouldn't really work, or it would work, but it would be very low pressure.
就像，因为有些人会说，哦，生成错误答案的模型显然无法验证，但它实际上是可以的，因为试想一下，就像给你的花园浇水一样。所以，如果你同时打开所有的区域，那么它就不会真正起作用，或者它会起作用，但压力会非常低。
And so you wouldn't get the same kind of watering. But like, if you're asking it to verify an answer you've already generated, that's kind of like only watering one zone, you know? Because it's like easier to verify than to have to generate the answer. And so it'll actually do a much better job. Yes, there, there is this, I've been working through this.
所以你无法获得同样的浇水效果。但是，如果你要求它验证你已经生成的答案，那就像只给一个区域浇水，你知道吗？因为它比生成答案更容易验证。所以它实际上会做得更好。是的，确实有这个，我一直在研究这个问题。
I want to make sure we move on so we don't run too long, but I have been starting to use some of the code AI stuff. And it's one of the things that I realized is you, when you interact with another person, you would normally have some distribution model of how good they are at what you're asking them to do. Can I give them a high level complex task and they'll accomplish it? Or do I need to help them make an outline? So if I'm talking to another person at work and be like, hey, I want you to do this, but can you come back to me with a plan once you've sort of like thought about it and looked at it?
我想确保我们继续前进，这样我们就不会超时，但我已经开始使用一些AI代码工具了。我意识到的一件事是，当你与另一个人互动时，你通常会对他们完成你要求的事情的能力有一个分布模型。我可以给他们一个高水平的复杂任务，他们能完成吗？还是我需要帮助他们列个大纲？所以如果我在工作中和另一个人交谈，说，嘿，我想让你做这个，但你能在思考并查看之后给我一个计划吗？
Let's talk about the plan. Then you go work and then come back to me and like, let's do a check-in, you know, from time to time. But we don't treat the LLMs that way. We just give them arbitrarily complex tasks and just let them go. And so this thing that you're mentioning, people were pointing out that it can often be helpful to say, first, what I'm looking for is a plan on how we could accomplish this.
我们来讨论一下这个计划。然后你去工作，然后再回来找我，我们不时地进行一次检查，你知道。但我们并不那样对待大语言模型（LLM）。我们只是给它们任意复杂的任务，然后就让它们去做了。所以你提到的这件事，人们指出，先说“我想要的是一个关于我们如何完成这个任务的计划”，这通常会有所帮助。
And then, you know, let's get that plan really, really good. And then once you have a plan, then now like the plan is good, let's go execute on it. But let's do it step by step. Like I only want you to do the first part of the plan and then only the second part and then only, you know, and so by doing it that way, you to do the first part of the plan and then only the second part and then only, you know, and so by doing it that way you end up getting more points of interaction, but also, you know, better quality, even if you just auto-approve everything that it,
然后，你知道，让我们把那个计划做得非常好。一旦你有了计划，现在计划很好了，让我们去执行它。但我们要一步一步来。我只想让你做计划的第一部分，然后只做第二部分，然后只做，你知道，通过这种方式，你最终会得到更多的互动点，而且质量也更好，即使你只是自动批准它所说的所有内容，
that it says and you don't do that interaction. Yeah, yeah, totally. That makes sense. I don't know. I, maybe we don't anthropomorphize the LLMs enough or too much. Like I'm not sure where in the spectrum we are. And then of course they're always changing and getting better. So, you know, whatever you were doing before doesn't always work in the future. Yeah, we should definitely do a show on co-pilot. That's a desperate show that needs to happen. How to talk to your computer. How to train you.
而你不进行那种互动。是的，是的，完全正确。这很有道理。我不知道。我，也许我们对大语言模型的拟人化不够，或者太多了。我不确定我们在光谱的哪个位置。当然，它们总是在变化和变得更好。所以，你知道，你以前做的任何事情在未来并不总是有效。是的，我们绝对应该做一个关于Copilot的节目。那是一个迫切需要做的节目。如何与你的电脑交谈。如何训练你。
Are we eventually going to have to have like the right way? Yeah. Like communication skills classes with like appropriate ways to interact with your chat bot. Oh, interesting. Like those, those communication classes in gen ed that I thought were useless, they're actually useful. I can talk to my computer with them.
我们最终是否必须要有正确的方法？是的。就像沟通技巧课程，教你与聊天机器人互动的适当方式。哦，有趣。就像那些我以为没用的通识教育沟通课程，它们实际上是有用的。我可以用它们与我的电脑交谈。
Okay. All right. Well, let's just, let's just hard pivot again. There it is. I did it again just for you. All right. Memory management. All right. Well, let's just hard pivot again. There it is. I did it again just for you. All right. Memory management.
好的。好吧，让我们再次进行硬转折。就是这样。我又为你做了一次。好的。内存管理。好的。让我们再次进行硬转折。就是这样。我又为你做了一次。好的。内存管理。
Memory management. So I suggested this topic. I feel like Patrick is going to know a lot more than I am, but I will start by talking about why I suggested it. We were having an issue at work where we um, you know, we were just blowing up on memory and the pod would die and very, this is like not an uncommon thing, um, where you run out of memory and then the OS just starts like machine gunning your program. Um, and, uh, you know, it made me realize like, you know, as, as one of the more senior kind of like engineers or developers at the company that like, this
内存管理。所以我建议了这个话题。我觉得Patrick会比我了解得多得多，但我会先谈谈我为什么建议它。我们在工作中遇到了一个问题，我们，你知道，我们的内存爆炸了，Pod（容器）死掉了，这非常，这并不是一件罕见的事情，你知道，当你内存耗尽时，操作系统就开始像机关枪一样扫射你的程序。而且，你知道，这让我意识到，作为公司里比较资深的工程师或开发人员之一，这
is a skill that's not very accessible. Like there's aren't a lot of people who know what to do when things run out of memory, like, like, uh, you know, a lot of people might just start randomly turning stuff off or you might have some intuition, but like, what's the principal thing that's imagine like you walk into a code base, you're at McKinsey or Deloitte or something. And you're, yeah, this is like the job from hell I'm about to describe, but like your task is just walking into some random company's code base and
是一项不太容易获得的技能。没有多少人知道当内存耗尽时该怎么办，就像，你知道，很多人可能只是开始随机关闭东西，或者你可能有一些直觉，但原则上是什么呢？想象一下，你走进一个代码库，你在麦肯锡或德勤之类的公司。是的，这是我即将描述的地狱般的工作，但你的任务只是走进某个随机公司的代码库，
reducing their memory footprint. Yeah. How do you go about doing that in like a principled way? And how do you maintain sort of the right knowledge about your system so that it doesn't get to the point where it's blowing up and everything? So that's really the motivator. And so I think we'll dive into a bunch of different things that you can do both to like catch, detect these things and also to mitigate.
减少他们的内存占用。是的。你如何以一种有原则的方式做到这一点？你如何保持关于你的系统的正确知识，以便它不会达到爆炸和一切都崩溃的地步？所以这才是真正的动力。所以我认为我们将深入探讨你可以做的许多不同的事情，既可以捕捉、检测这些事情，也可以进行缓解。
You guys got a better explanation of that topic. I misinterpreted it to mean just broadly all the things about memory management, because to me, memory management is as a C++ program or something that is a uh, haunts your, haunts your dreams at night. Um, but, but I don't know. I think, I think we're gonna do a little bit of a dabble, dabble across, across boats.
你们对这个话题有更好的解释吗？我误解了它，以为它泛指所有关于内存管理的事情，因为对我来说，内存管理是作为一名C++程序员，或者某种会让你在夜里做噩梦的事情。但是，但我不知道。我想，我想我们会稍微涉猎一下，跨越不同的领域。
I mean, they are, are interconnected and I think your statement is interesting. I hadn't really thought about it that way, but when something's running too slow, the ability to make it go faster, it you know maybe is more at hand for people. You study that in school right, like big O notation, algorithm, so generally people have some experience in sort of like data structures or algorithmic approaches to improvement of their code. And then there are levels past that, but people can kind of see to them because they're near to them. So there's things like optimizing for assembly code generation or optimizing with SIMD or GPU offloading.
我的意思是，它们是相互关联的，我认为你的陈述很有趣。我之前并没有那样想过，但当某件事运行太慢时，让它变快的能力，你知道，可能对人们来说更容易掌握。你在学校里学过这个，对吧，比如大O符号、算法，所以通常人们在数据结构或算法改进代码方面有一些经验。然后还有超越这些的层次，但人们可以看得到它们，因为它们离他们很近。所以有一些事情，比如优化汇编代码生成，或者使用SIMD或GPU卸载进行优化。
These kinds of things that you can do multi multi-threading the right. Like, but I feel like people are exposed to those a lot more than like you said, the tooling is more under or not used as often for a lot of folks. And just in general, most people don't think about memory because it's sort of like a pass fail thing, right? Like you run your code and if it finishes, you know how long it took sort of intuitively because you were waiting for it, but you don't really know how much memory it used. Right.
这些事情你可以做，多线程，对吧。就像，但我感觉人们接触这些比你说的要多得多，工具的使用频率对很多人来说并不高。而且总的来说，大多数人并不考虑内存，因为它有点像通过/失败的事情，对吧？就像你运行你的代码，如果它完成了，你知道它花了多长时间，因为你在等它，但你真的不知道它用了多少内存。对吧。
I hadn't really thought about it, but yeah, I, I, I guess you're right. Like it's sort of one of those, uh, you, like if, if your program busts out the memory size and you don't know of an obvious thing that you were doing that you could just not do that thing, then yeah, what do you do next? Yeah, so maybe you should start by kind of explaining to people like how memory works like in a program. That'd be like a good way to keep it off. So you go to Best Buy and you buy the kind of DDR RAM that your motherboard supports and your CPU. I mean, it's complex. Even that part, right? That's true.
我之前没想过，但是的，我想你是对的。就像它是那种，如果你，如果你的程序超出了内存大小，而你不知道有什么显而易见的事情可以不做，那么，接下来你该怎么办？是的，所以也许你应该先向人们解释一下程序中的内存是如何工作的。那将是一个很好的开始方式。所以你去百思买，购买你的主板和CPU支持的那种DDR内存。我的意思是，这很复杂。即使是那部分，对吧？那是真的。
Dude, it's like, it's all the memory technologies. Memory can also be talking about L1, L2 caches, RAM. Most of the time we're talking about RAM. And then as Jason mentioned, if you're in a multi-user situation where you're submitting something on Kubernetes or Docker or whatever up into a cloud, then have a hard memory limit because they want you to play nice with other systems. I like to motivate my memory. Okay.
伙计，这就像是所有的内存技术。内存也可以指L1、L2缓存、RAM。大多数时候我们谈论的是RAM。然后正如Jason提到的，如果你处于一个多用户环境，你在Kubernetes或Docker或任何东西上提交东西到云端，那么就要有一个硬性的内存限制，因为他们希望你与其他系统友好相处。我喜欢激励我的内存。好的。
All right. We're looking at meme pictures while I'm trying to talk now. Okay. All right. We're looking at meme pictures while I'm trying to talk now. And who said we shouldn't Twitch stream? Okay. It was me. All right. You're distracting me. Okay. So the idea of memory is when your computer is, you know,
好的。我现在说话的时候你们在看表情包。好的。好的。我现在说话的时候你们在看表情包。是谁说我们不应该在Twitch上直播的？好的。是我。好的。你在分散我的注意力。好的。所以内存的概念是，当你的电脑是，你知道，
there is a certain amount of things that fit into CPU registers. So the little bits of variables, but once you start having strings, arrays of objects, these things aren't going to fit in the registers, the sort of like very, very small, very efficient, what your computer CPU operates on. So they may be stored out in L1 or L2 cache, but ultimately that cache gets filled in from your system memory, your RAM. And that RAM is relatively slow to access, but way faster than going out to disk, even an SSD. So SSDs, hard drives are pretty slow,
CPU寄存器中能容纳一定数量的东西。所以是变量的小位，但一旦你开始有字符串、对象数组，这些东西就不会放进寄存器里，那种非常、非常小、非常高效、你的电脑CPU操作的东西。所以它们可能存储在L1或L2缓存中，但最终该缓存是从你的系统内存（RAM）中填充的。而RAM访问速度相对较慢，但比访问磁盘（即使是SSD）要快得多。所以SSD、硬盘驱动器相当慢，
RAM's a lot faster, cache down to registers. So fitting in memory can be about staying in the cache size because you get a lot of speed up. But then more like what Jason is talking about is just how much total memory consumption your computer has. So if you're like me, one of the first times you bump into this is you write a recursive function and you screw up the terminating condition.
RAM快得多，缓存到寄存器。所以适应内存可能就是关于保持在缓存大小之内，因为你会获得很多速度提升。但更像Jason所说的是你的电脑总共消耗了多少内存。所以如果你像我一样，你第一次遇到这种情况时，就是你写了一个递归函数，然后搞砸了终止条件。
And so your computer just keeps every time it recurses into the function, pushes all of the state into the stack and just keeps pushing and pushing and pushing into the stack. And eventually your stack grows too big and your computer crashes and it's saving some system state into memory. But the other way you can run into it is as you're reading data in, if you are deriving a lot of data and just keep adding to it, then you will crash.
所以你的电脑每次递归进入函数时，都会把所有的状态推入堆栈，并不断地推入堆栈。最终你的堆栈变得太大，你的电脑崩溃了，它正在将一些系统状态保存到内存中。但你遇到这种情况的另一种方式是，当你读取数据时，如果你正在导出大量数据并不断添加，那么你就会崩溃。
And how you handle that can vary a lot. But ultimately, the memory management happens at several levels. So your program that you're writing, depending on the language, the compiler, the runtime, is tracking the objects. Unless you're in sort of like C++ or C, in general, it's trying to free up as much memory as it can as it goes along, as you're not using it anymore, so that the longer your program runs, it doesn't just consume arbitrarily more memory over time.
你如何处理这个问题可能会有很大不同。但最终，内存管理发生在几个层面。所以你正在编写的程序，取决于语言、编译器、运行时，正在跟踪对象。除非你是在C++或C中，通常情况下，它会尽量在进行过程中释放尽可能多的内存，当你不再使用它时，这样你的程序运行时间越长，它就不会随着时间的推移而消耗任意多的内存。
So in C++ or C, you kind of need to do that yourself, or some people will handle that with shared pointers, unique pointers, things that will, so-called smart pointers to help them out. But in languages like Java or something else, like maybe Python, you'll get garbage collection. So the runtime is trying to monitor, hey, no one's referring to this bit of memory anymore, so I'm going to go clean it up and kind of organize it. In Rust, which is becoming more important,
所以在C++或C中，你需要自己做这件事，或者有些人会用共享指针、唯一指针来处理，也就是所谓的智能指针来帮助他们。但在Java或其他语言中，比如Python，你会得到垃圾回收。所以运行时正在尝试监控，嘿，没有人再引用这块内存了，所以我去清理它并整理它。在Rust中，它变得越来越重要，
that is done through ownership so that it's more efficient, but still kind of done for you. And there's careful tracking of who owns the memory and when they don't do it, not using it anymore. But once you go past that, ultimately getting memory, so when you allocate memory, either through an allocation command
这是通过所有权完成的，所以它更高效，但仍然是为你完成的。并且仔细跟踪谁拥有内存，以及当他们不再使用它时。但一旦你超越了这一点，最终获取内存，所以当你分配内存时，无论是通过分配命令
or just you ask for something and it generates the memory for you. So not a fixed sized object, but something that you're dynamically allocating. That's a call to your operating system. And so your language will have a way of asking the operating system for, hey, I need, I need some memory. And your operating system is trying to give you blocks of memory that you can use and space in that. And then when you go to free it, it's trying to keep it, you know, coherent and together, but also across all the programs running. So the first thing people will do is, you know, open their task manager or, you know, thread monitor and look for
还是你只是要求某样东西，它为你生成内存。所以不是固定大小的对象，而是你动态分配的东西。那是对操作系统的调用。所以你的语言会有一种方式向操作系统询问，嘿，我需要一些内存。而你的操作系统正在尝试给你你可以使用的内存块和其中的空间。然后当你去释放它时，它试图保持它，你知道，连贯和在一起，但也跨越所有运行的程序。所以人们做的第一件事是，你知道，打开他们的任务管理器或线程监视器，寻找
the operating system's record of how much memory your program is taking. Because ultimately, like Jason was saying, his pod got killed, right? What he's saying is the operating system, the hypervisor, is monitoring memory consumption by how many times the program has asked for more memory. And when it hits its limit its job is to protect itself and all the other programs running and will terminate your program and force it to free up all of its memory because it'll terminate it and then go okay now I can free that memory and so it'll free itself up so
操作系统关于你的程序占用了多少内存的记录。因为最终，就像Jason说的，他的Pod被杀死了，对吧？他所说的是操作系统、管理程序正在通过程序请求更多内存的次数来监控内存消耗。当它达到限制时，它的工作是保护自己和所有其他正在运行的程序，并将终止你的程序并强制它释放其所有内存，因为它会终止它，然后说“好的，现在我可以释放那块内存了”，所以它会释放自己，所以
watching the sort of first course of action would be monitoring what the operating system is reporting as how much memory is being used. So I think probably the most obvious one, but you know, walking through the steps, that's where you're going to find that. Similarly, looking when your job finishes at a log of what's called the high watermark. So the high watermark represents your computer, your program was hopefully borrowing memory and then giving it back as it wasn't needed anymore. And so you may use a terabyte of memory over the course of your program running,
观察第一种行动方案将是监控操作系统报告的正在使用的内存量。所以我认为这可能是最明显的，但是，你知道，一步步走下来，这就是你会发现的地方。同样，在你的作业完成时查看所谓的“高水位线”日志。所以高水位线代表你的电脑，你的程序希望是在借用内存，然后在不需要时归还它。所以你的程序在运行过程中可能会使用一TB的内存，
but if you were only using a gigabyte and then as you didn't need it, you were freeing it and getting another gigabyte, freeing it and getting another gigabyte. freeing it and getting another gigabyte. We can talk about better ways of doing that maybe later, but you could go through a full terabyte but the high watermark, the largest amount of memory you ever used was only one gigabyte. And the way to know that is to either run something along with your job that is monitoring
但如果你只使用了一GB，然后在不需要时释放它，又得到另一GB，释放它，又得到另一GB。释放它，又得到另一GB。我们以后可以谈谈更好的做法，但你可能会用掉整整一TB，但高水位线，你曾经使用过的最大内存量只有一GB。知道这一点的方法是，要么在你的作业运行的同时运行一些监控
what the operating system is doing. There are other tools for that, more built, more built-in, but basically monitoring that high water mark and then saying I want to stay below, you know, if your pod has 16 gigabytes or whatever, saying hey I don't want to get more than 13 or 14 because if I'm getting up past that there's a strong chance that unless I know very clearly what the max is gonna be it'd be very easy for a spike to cause it to bump over the 16 gigabyte and just get force killed and so if you don't want to do that you would sort of monitor those so the easiest way to tell how much your program is using in
操作系统正在做什么的东西。还有其他工具可以做到这一点，更多是内置的，但基本上是监控那个高水位线，然后说我想保持在，你知道，如果你的Pod有16GB或什么，说嘿，我不想超过13或14，因为如果我超过了那个，除非我非常清楚最大值会是多少，否则很容易因为一个峰值导致它超过16GB并被强制杀死，所以如果你不想那样做，你会监控那些，所以告诉你的程序正在使用多少内存的最简单方法是
general is looking in the operating system. Yeah that makes sense and like as a as a you know I just as a desktop user, sometimes you've seen this where, you know, maybe you've had some program go off the rails or or whatever, but like you it uses all of your RAM and then you find like you can't even move the mouse. And like everything's kind of deadlocked and you're kind of hosed, you have to hit the hard reset. Well, like, you know, on Amazon, they don't want to do that. Like Amazon doesn't want your program
通常是查看操作系统。是的，这很有道理，就像作为一个桌面用户，有时你见过这种情况，你知道，也许你有一些程序失控了，或者其他什么，但它使用了你所有的RAM，然后你发现你甚至无法移动鼠标。就像一切都死锁了，你被困住了，你必须进行硬重置。好吧，你知道，在亚马逊上，他们不想那样做。亚马逊不想你的程序
to cause the entire machine to like lock up and potentially ruin other people's programs who don't even know you exist or whatever on that same machine, right? And so they will really aggressively, so the way it works when you're running in the cloud is you say, like, I promise you, Mr. Cloud, I'm only going to use 10 gigs of RAM. And what happens is they constantly monitor and
导致整台机器锁定，并可能毁掉其他甚至不知道你存在的程序，或者在那台机器上的其他程序，对吧？所以他们会非常激进，所以当你在云端运行时，它的工作方式是你承诺，嘿，云先生，我只会使用10GB的RAM。发生的情况是他们不断监控，
they can't actually prevent you from using 11 gigs because of just, I guess, the history of compute and languages and everything like they can't actually stop you so so what they do instead is if you go over the 10 gigabyte mark for more than a few seconds it just kills your entire pod and that's their way of ultimately protecting themselves or even sometimes there are situations where and this doesn't happen very often, but you can imagine, let's say you and two other programs are sharing a pod, sharing a physical machine,
他们实际上无法阻止你使用11GB，因为仅仅是，我想，计算和语言的历史等等，他们实际上无法阻止你，所以他们所做的是，如果你超过了10GB的标记超过几秒钟，它就会直接杀死你的整个Pod，这是他们最终保护自己的方式，甚至有时会有这种情况，这并不经常发生，但你可以想象，假设你和另外两个程序共享一个Pod，共享一台物理机器，
and those other two programs both go above their watermark, and that causes the whole machine to start to run out of memory. It might just kill all three of your pods, and so that wasn't even your fault. So that does happen, but it will definitely happen if you go over the limit that you claimed when you started the program.
而那另外两个程序都超过了它们的水位线，这导致整台机器开始内存耗尽。它可能只是杀死了你们所有的三个Pod，所以那甚至不是你的错。所以这种情况确实会发生，但如果你超过了你在启动程序时声明的限制，它肯定会发生。
And so also those limits decide how much Amazon charges you. So it becomes really important to have tight bounds around your memory. Yeah, the thing you point out is a good point. So when you're running on a server, there's one set of behavior. When you're running locally on a desktop, not in a way that replicates the server,
而且这些限制也决定了亚马逊向你收取多少费用。所以对你的内存有严格的限制变得非常重要。是的，你指出的这一点很好。所以当你在服务器上运行时，有一套行为。当你在本地桌面上运行时，不是以复制服务器的方式，
you can sometimes bump into an issue where, like you said, your whole computer slows down. That's one thing. although I feel like modern operating systems have gotten better about protecting themselves by limiting that from happening. But what they will do instead, because they wanna try to let your program finish, is they'll start giving you,
你有时会遇到一个问题，就像你说的，你的整台电脑变慢了。这是一回事。虽然我觉得现代操作系统在通过限制这种情况发生来保护自己方面做得更好了。但他们会做的是，因为他们想尝试让你的程序完成，他们会开始给你，
telling you that you have more memory, but that memory is actually coming off of disk. And so what they'll do is they'll say, hey, here's a new chunk of memory. They'll take your old memory, actually coming off of disk. And so what they'll do is they'll say, hey, here's a new chunk of memory. They'll take your old memory, put it out to disk, it's called paging. So they'll page your memory out to disk, and then they'll give you new memory that you can use and you're writing to that. And then you go try to look up something in the other address that was corresponding to what got wrote off disk. And it'll go, okay, hang on, I'm going to put your current one on disk and bring that one back in.
告诉你你有更多的内存，但那块内存实际上是来自磁盘的。所以他们会做的是，他们会说，嘿，这是一块新的内存。他们会拿走你的旧内存，实际上来自磁盘。所以他们会做的是，他们会说，嘿，这是一块新的内存。他们会拿走你的旧内存，把它放到磁盘上，这叫分页。所以他们会把你的内存分页到磁盘上，然后他们会给你你可以使用的新内存，你正在写入它。然后你去尝试查找对应于被写到磁盘上的那个地址的其他地址中的东西。它会说，好的，等一下，我要把你当前的那个放到磁盘上，把那个带回来。
That happens transparently to you, except your program sort of gets paused waiting for that swap to happen. But you'll hear that called thrashing. So it's thrashing because it's writing these pages in and out of your disk and you have to kind of wait. And so your program's runtime just goes exponentially longer because it's sort of stuck doing this
这对你来说是透明发生的，除了你的程序有点暂停等待那个交换发生。但你会听到这被称为“抖动”（thrashing）。所以它在抖动，因为它在把这些页面写进写出你的磁盘，你必须等待。所以你的程序的运行时间呈指数级增长，因为它有点卡在这里
over and over and over again, with the pages coming in and out and in and out. But you wouldn't necessarily know that that was happening because nothing would sort of indicate. And it does this because you may have something like your browser open that's taking, you know, lots and lots of RAM, but you're not using it right now, you're doing development. And so you actually want the operating system to be able to take all of that browser memory and put it out to disk.
一遍又一遍地做，页面进进出出。但你未必知道发生了这种情况，因为没有什么会指示。它这样做是因为你可能有像你的浏览器打开，占用了，你知道，大量的RAM，但你现在没有使用它，你在进行开发。所以你实际上希望操作系统能够获取所有那些浏览器内存并把它放到磁盘上。
And until you go click on it again, it's sort of just hanging out, chill on disk, and you can bring it back and it pops right back up. It's a little slow. So if you ever switch back to an app when you're using a lot of RAM and it's sort of like sluggish in the beginning, this is what you're experiencing.
直到你再次点击它，它有点只是挂在那里，在磁盘上休息，你可以把它带回来，它会立刻弹出来。有点慢。所以如果你在大量使用RAM时切换回一个应用程序，它在开始时有点迟钝，这就是你正在经历的。
The operating system is trying to let everyone have their cake and eat it too, and this is the trade-off that they make. Yeah, totally, totally makes sense. So I think, yeah, you totally hit the nail on the head. The first thing to realize is that you need to pay attention to both the high watermark and just the average memory consumption and the variance. So if there's really high variance,
操作系统试图让每个人都鱼与熊掌兼得，这就是他们做出的权衡。是的，完全，完全有道理。所以我认为，是的，你完全说中了要点。首先要意识到的是，你需要关注高水位线以及平均内存消耗和方差。所以如果方差真的很大，
when you run on the cloud, you can choose like a minimum amount of memory to reserve, and then you can choose an upper bound. And the way this is implemented in the cloud is, you know, you're guaranteed to get your minimum amount of memory. Let's say you ask for four to 10 gigs. You're guaranteed to get four gigs, but just, there's other people sharing that machine. And so it's really just whatever they're doing.
当你在云端运行时，你可以选择预留的最小内存量，然后你可以选择一个上限。这在云端实现的方式是，你知道，你保证得到你的最小内存量。假设你要求4到10GB。你保证得到4GB，但只是，有其他人共享那台机器。所以这真的只是他们正在做的任何事情。
So if you say, I want four to 10 gigs, it'll give you four. And if you go over four, it'll check and see, okay, what are the other people on this machine doing? If they're not using all the remaining RAM, they'll give you another gig. And so your process continues and it gives you, you're up to five gig now and you're paying for five gig and then you can go six, seven, eight, all the way up to 10, right? And it's not linear, but you get my point.
所以如果你说，我想要4到10GB，它会给你4GB。如果你超过4GB，它会检查并查看，好的，这台机器上的其他人正在做什么？如果他们没有使用所有剩余的RAM，他们会再给你1GB。所以你的进程继续，它给你，你现在达到5GB，你正在为5GB付费，然后你可以达到6、7、8，一直到10，对吧？它不是线性的，但你明白我的意思。
But here's the problem. If you're at five gig and you go over and it says, oh, I can't give you six because there's just nothing left on this physical machine. Well, guess what it's gonna do? It's gonna kill your pod. So for a lot of web services they actually set the minimum and the maximum to the same number and this way you don't have to ever worry about
但问题就在这里。如果你在5GB，你超过了，它说，哦，我不能给你6GB，因为这台物理机器上什么都没有了。好吧，猜猜它会做什么？它会杀死你的Pod。所以对于许多Web服务，他们实际上将最小值和最大值设置为相同的数字，这样你就永远不必担心
growing. You're just statically getting 10 gig and then you can use 0 to 10 of that at your leisure but you never have to worry about getting killed because you can't grow. And so but in a way that's kind of just like moving the problem somewhere else because you can obviously get killed for going over the max. So it all gets pretty complicated which is why you know it's it's it's an extremely important skill as an engineer to be able to be on top of that. I'll talk about what I do on the Python side and then I'll let Patrick jump into the C and C++ side. On
增长。你只是静态地得到10GB，然后你可以随意使用其中的0到10GB，但你永远不必担心因为无法增长而被杀死。所以，但在某种程度上，这就像把问题转移到别处，因为你显然会因为超过最大值而被杀死。所以这一切变得非常复杂，这就是为什么，你知道，作为一名工程师，能够掌握这一点是一项极其重要的技能。我会谈谈我在Python方面所做的事情，然后我会让Patrick跳到C和C++方面。在
Python there's two tools you really should become familiar with. One is called PSUtil. And this is a cross-platform tool, despite the fact that when I hear PS and PSUtil, I immediately think of Linux. But they have total Windows support. So total cross-platform, it will tell you your CPU usage, the machine's CPU usage, memory usage, et cetera, et cetera. If you're running in the cloud, it will give you the usage of your pod.
Python中，有两个工具你应该真正熟悉。一个叫PSUtil。这是一个跨平台工具，尽管当我听到PS和PSUtil时，我立刻想到Linux。但它们有完全的Windows支持。所以完全跨平台，它会告诉你你的CPU使用率、机器的CPU使用率、内存使用率等等。如果你在云端运行，它会给你你的Pod的使用率。
So, you know, the machine could have 128 gigs of RAM. If your pod only has 10 gigs of RAM, that's what is gonna show up in PSUtil. And so you know you could imagine doing things like taking the output of PSUtil and writing it to Datadog or writing it to a Postgres database somewhere where you go and look at that. This is all very common. Another tool that's really important is TraceMalloc and so you know PSUtil gives you this snapshot and it asks the kernel for this information so it's relatively cheap like maybe even free. TraceMalloc is not cheap and so
所以，你知道，机器可能有128GB的RAM。如果你的Pod只有10GB的RAM，那才是PSUtil中会显示的内容。所以你知道你可以想象做一些事情，比如获取PSUtil的输出并将其写入Datadog或写入某个Postgres数据库，你去那里查看。这都很常见。另一个非常重要的工具是TraceMalloc，所以你知道PSUtil给你这个快照，它向内核询问这个信息，所以它相对便宜，甚至可能是免费的。TraceMalloc不便宜，所以
what TraceMalloc does is it you you say start tracing and it keeps track of all the memory allocations and it builds like a ledger of all of that. And then you say stop tracing and it freezes that, you know, probably converts it to some other data structures that are easier to manipulate. And then you can go through and get high watermark and a bunch of other interesting statistics. You can get like, you know, what are the files that generated the most memory consumption? That's extremely useful. You can also filter that down and say, you know, I want the files that generated the most memory usage, but I don't need like torch.py. Because like clearly PyTorch.py generated like 99%
TraceMalloc所做的是，你，你说开始跟踪，它会跟踪所有的内存分配，并建立一个所有这些的分类账。然后你说停止跟踪，它会冻结那个，你知道，可能把它转换成一些更容易操作的其他数据结构。然后你可以通过它并获得高水位线和一堆其他有趣的统计数据。你可以得到，你知道，哪些文件产生了最多的内存消耗？这极其有用。你也可以过滤它并说，你知道，我想要产生最多内存使用的文件，但我不需要像torch.py这样的东西。因为显然PyTorch.py产生了像99%
of the memory if I'm running an LLM, but that's not helpful for me, right? So you can filter it and everything. Both of those are amazing tools. Every time I start a project, I always have some way of running those tools pretty easily. Some type of util library with a context manager so that I can do trace malloc and psutil at will. And that's pretty much all you need to get you most of the
的内存，如果我正在运行一个大语言模型，但这对我没有帮助，对吧？所以你可以过滤它等等。这两个都是很棒的工具。每次我开始一个项目，我总是有一种方法可以很容易地运行这些工具。某种带有上下文管理器的util库，这样我就可以随意进行trace malloc和psutil。这基本上就是你需要让你达到大部分
way there. I guess the other thing I would add, which I think is universally applicable, is to have a place to send that information. So at the company I work at now, we use Datadog. In the past, I've worked at bigger companies which had bespoke solutions. Oh, I did use Prometheus at another company. A lot of different options, but just having a way to collect and aggregate that information is really useful.
路程所需要的全部。我想我会补充的另一件事，我认为是普遍适用的，就是有一个地方可以发送这些信息。所以在我现在工作的公司，我们使用Datadog。过去，我在更大的公司工作过，它们有定制的解决方案。哦，我在另一家公司确实使用过Prometheus。有很多不同的选择，但有一种方法来收集和汇总这些信息真的很有用。
I haven't actually used either of those, but you know, it is important, like you're saying, actually making sure you have a good way of. At least having a special mode where logs are coming out with priority. So even if your pod gets killed, you know what was happening right before that happened can be overlooked because right in those last few seconds, or second or milliseconds is like exactly the thing you need to see. And so sometimes you need to be a little careful to make sure that you're not like waiting for a buffer flush or something to happen, and you're not getting out
我实际上没有使用过其中任何一个，但你知道，这很重要，就像你说的，确保你有一个好的方法。至少有一个特殊的模式，日志以优先级输出。所以即使你的Pod被杀死了，你知道在那之前发生了什么，因为就在最后几秒钟，或者秒或毫秒，正是你需要看到的东西。所以有时你需要小心一点，确保你没有像在等待缓冲区刷新或什么事情发生，而你没有得到
that insight that you needed at the last moments. Another tool that I assume probably can run on servers, but we mostly run on desktops when we need is Valgrind. So similar to what Jason is describing, running Valgrind will give you a lot of insight about how much memory used, but also other related memory adjacent topics to not just size usage, but total number of allocations. So every time your program
你在最后时刻需要的那个洞察。另一个我假设可能可以在服务器上运行，但我们主要在需要时在桌面上运行的工具是Valgrind。所以类似于Jason所描述的，运行Valgrind会给你很多关于使用了多少内存的洞察，但也包括其他相关的内存邻近主题，不仅是大小使用，还有分配的总数。所以每次你的程序
does an allocation, there's some cost to be paid. And then every time you free, there's a cost to be paid. And so the more you do allocate and free, so like in my example before, you know, gigabyte at a time through a terabyte, that's there is going to be a cost to that that you wouldn't necessarily have if you didn't do as many transactions. And there's also cost associated with as you borrow and free and borrow and free. Sometimes the OS needs to do optimization, cleaning up, making sure that you know, it collects back stuff it has so it can give it out to other programs. And so Valgrind will help track all that,
进行分配，都有一些成本要支付。然后每次你释放，都有一个成本要支付。所以你分配和释放得越多，所以就像我之前的例子，一次一GB，通过一TB，那是有成本的，如果你没有进行那么多交易，你就不一定会有。而且当你借用和释放、借用和释放时，也有相关的成本。有时操作系统需要进行优化、清理，确保你知道，它收回它拥有的东西，以便它可以分发给其他程序。所以Valgrind将帮助跟踪所有这些，
but it'll also do things like tracking which pieces of memory you have and haven't initialized, which ones belong to your program. So if your program tries to read, we were talking about arbitrary code exploits earlier in the show as one of the news items, but what happens is you try to read a piece of memory you weren't supposed to. Now, Valgrind can't
但它也会做一些事情，比如跟踪你已经和没有初始化的内存片段，哪些属于你的程序。所以如果你的程序试图读取，我们之前在节目中谈到了任意代码漏洞作为新闻项目之一，但发生的情况是你试图读取一块你不应该读取的内存。现在，Valgrind不能
always tell if you're reading from, you know, an array that happens to be next to your current array, right? Like, but it can tell if you're reading from a location that's just clearly not part of what you're supposed to be, and so it can report those to you and can be very useful. I will say it's not the easiest tool to run. So in general, I don't just run it because I'm bored and like looking for something to do. But if you have a problem being able to reach for those tools can be very valuable and tracking it down.
总是判断你是否在读取，你知道，恰好在你当前数组旁边的数组，对吧？但是，它可以判断你是否在读取一个显然不属于你应该读取的位置，所以它可以向你报告这些，并且在追踪它时非常有用。我会说它不是最容易运行的工具。所以总的来说，我不会因为无聊和想找点事做就运行它。但如果你有一个问题，能够使用这些工具会非常有价值，并追踪它。
Yeah, that makes sense. I remember, and this is a long time ago, this tool might not even exist. I use this thing in C++ called address sanitizer. Yeah. Yeah, that was pretty good. I had that in, but then I removed it. But yes, there are compiler options where you can turn on address sanitization. And what it will do is configure it so that, again, if you try to read from memory that
是的，这很有道理。我记得，这是很久以前的事了，这个工具可能都不存在了。我使用过这个叫地址清理器（address sanitizer）的C++工具。是的。是的，那相当不错。我把它放进去了，但我后来删除了它。但是是的，有一些编译器选项可以让你开启地址清理。它会做的是配置它，这样，同样，如果你试图读取内存，
hasn't been, you know, that you're not supposed to be, that you basically, the compiler will alert you to that. Hey, you're this thing here you're doing may read from uninitialized memory or may, you know, be dereferencing a pointer that doesn't point to something valid. And so it'll catch, it'll catch those things for you. So Valgrind does all that and more, but it's kind of expensive. But it does it after the fact, right? So you don't compile with Valgrind does all that and more, but it's kind of expensive. But it does it after the fact, right? So you don't compile with Valgrind. So Valgrind is doing it to your...
还没有被，你知道，你不应该被，你基本上，编译器会提醒你。嘿，你在这里做的这件事可能会读取未初始化的内存，或者可能，你知道，正在解引用一个不指向有效东西的指针。所以它会捕捉，它会为你捕捉那些东西。所以Valgrind做了所有这些以及更多，但它有点昂贵。但它是在事后做的，对吧？所以你不会用Valgrind编译。所以Valgrind正在对你的...
So yeah, it's doing it after you've already built your program. The address sanitization is something that is like a compiler flag that you add. And so it's part of your program build. Got it. Okay. That makes sense. So Patrick, what do you do? You're using, you have 10 gigs of RAM.
所以是的，它是在你已经构建程序之后做的。地址清理是你添加的一个编译器标志。所以它是你程序构建的一部分。明白了。好的。这很有道理。所以Patrick，你做什么？你正在使用，你有10GB的RAM。
You can't, you don't want to pay for 11. Your program is sometimes fine, but sometimes it hits 11 gigs and gets killed. What do we do? Okay. Well, with that tee up, we'll talk about first reducing the amounts of data size that you're using. So one option can be to compress things. So now compression doesn't always mean like zipping it up, right? Like that would be counterintuitive, but sometimes you can trade memory cost for runtime.
你不能，你不想为11GB付费。你的程序有时很好，但有时它达到11GB并被杀死。我们该怎么办？好的。好吧，有了这个铺垫，我们先谈谈减少你正在使用的数据大小。所以一个选择可以是压缩东西。所以现在压缩并不总是意味着像压缩它一样，对吧？那将是违反直觉的，但有时你可以用内存成本换取运行时。
So if you think about, you know, I have a stock price, right? So you could naively say, I'm going to store a double of all of the stock prices. And you know, at every tick or every second, I'm going to store double for these stock prices. And then you can kind of work out how many seconds, how many stock tickers that you could track in your memory. So one way to say, hey, I need to save space is to figure out instead of storing, you know, a double for every position, which is overkill, hey, how do I do this in fixed point? You know, do stocks actually trade to one E minus something ridiculous, you know, amounts of precision, or can I use a sort of known thing? I would say that's a form of compression using fixed point math.
所以如果你想，你知道，我有一个股票价格，对吧？所以你可以天真地说，我要存储所有股票价格的双精度浮点数。而且，你知道，在每一个刻度或每一秒，我要为这些股票价格存储双精度浮点数。然后你可以算出你可以跟踪多少秒、多少股票代码在你的内存中。所以一种说，嘿，我需要节省空间的方法是找出，而不是存储，你知道，每个位置的双精度浮点数，这是过度的，嘿，我如何用定点数做这个？你知道，股票真的交易到1E减去某种荒谬的，你知道，精度的数量吗，还是我可以使用一种已知的东西？我会说那是一种使用定点数学的压缩形式。
Similarly, you could use something like an arithmetic encoding where you store how much the signal is moving by. So when, it always blew my mind when I was younger, but like, I had a CD player that said one bit DAC, and I was like, I knew enough to know that's really weird, like how do you have a one bit DAC and I was like, I knew enough to know that's really weird. Like how do you have a one bit DAC and why is it something they would boast about? Well, I still to this day don't know why they boast about it. Uh, but you can kind of figure out what a one bit DAC means, which is when it's playing
同样，你可以使用像算术编码这样的东西，你存储信号移动了多少。所以当，它总是让我年轻时感到震惊，但就像，我有一个说是一比特DAC的CD播放器，我当时知道足够多，知道那真的很奇怪，就像你怎么有一个一比特DAC，我当时知道足够多，知道那真的很奇怪。就像你怎么有一个一比特DAC，为什么这是他们会吹嘘的东西？好吧，直到今天我仍然不知道他们为什么要吹嘘它。呃，但你可以算出什么是一比特DAC，这意味着当它在播放
the digital audio signal, it basically at every timestamp is either a one or a zero. That's all you get when it's one bit. And if it's a one, they move the signal up and latch it. If it's zero, they move it down. And so if you wanted to have a steady signal, you would just do one zero, one zero, one zero at equal weight. And it would just bounce around at roughly the same value. But then if you had, you know, one, one, one, it's going to move ever so, you know, slowly up.
数字音频信号时，它基本上在每个时间戳要么是1要么是0。这就是你得到的一比特。如果是1，他们向上移动信号并锁存它。如果是0，他们向下移动它。所以如果你想有一个稳定的信号，你只需要以相等的权重做1、0、1、0、1、0。它就会在大致相同的值上跳动。但如果你有，你知道，1、1、1，它会移动得非常，你知道，缓慢地向上。
And as long as if those ones and zeros are coming out at a rate fast enough that you can match the changing rate of your output signal that you're wanting, Bob's your uncle, I guess, you're good to go. And so there, one bit at each thing is going to be a lot easier for your program to store. So those are things that are like nominally, I guess I would say as, as compression, but more just using the minimal amounts of data to represent
只要这些 0 和 1 产生的速度足够快，能够匹配你想要的输出信号的变化速率，那一切就搞定了。所以，每个数据点只用一位（bit）来表示，对你的程序来说存储起来会容易得多。这些做法名义上可以称为压缩，但其实更多是使用最少量的数据来表示
what you actually need to, even if it sometimes means sacrificing precision or runtime, because you, you have to convert those, those back. Um, another thing is like references to data. So if you think about, I store a bunch of web pages in memory for some reason, and web pages have all these repeated HTML tags in them. So you could go through and say, again, trading a lot of processing speed for memory.
你真正需要的内容，即使有时这意味着要牺牲精度或运行时间，因为你必须把它们转换回来。嗯，另一件事是数据引用。比如，如果你出于某种原因在内存中存储了一堆网页，而网页中包含大量重复的 HTML 标签。你可以遍历一遍，说——同样是牺牲大量处理速度来换取内存——
But you could say every time the string, I don't know what's a angle bracket P angle bracket. Like I'm going to have angle P angle bracket just represented by a single value that's a pointer to the string angle bracket P angle bracket. Probably not the best example. But if you have these strings repeated over and over and over in your memory, you can sort of make references to them and pull them out. And again, it's sort of make references to them and pull them out. And again, it's kind of compression, but kind of referencing where you kind of layer these things up so your total data size becomes a lot smaller.
你可以说，每当出现字符串，比如尖括号 P 尖括号，我就用一个指向该字符串的指针来代表它。这可能不是最好的例子。但如果你的内存中反复出现这些字符串，你可以对它们进行引用并提取出来。再说一次，这算是一种压缩，但更像是引用，通过将这些东西分层，使你的总数据量变得小得多。
But if you need to process it, then you kind of pay for it. And then by a similar thing, every time you kind of derive data on your sample, the instinct is to kind of do that ahead of time so it's ready to use. But if you have just vast amounts of data, it can be a problem. So you can do lazy initialization, which can help with other things as well.
但如果你需要处理它，你就得付出代价。类似地，每当你对样本进行数据派生时，直觉上会想提前做好，以便随时使用。但如果你有海量数据，这可能会成为问题。所以你可以使用延迟初始化，这在其他方面也有帮助。
But this is where you're sort of saying, I'm not going to derive this data until I need it. And then when I'm done using it, in that moment, I just let it go. And if I need it again, I'll just generate it again. And so you do this through all the pieces and it requires code and data change, but you're kind of going through the stuff
这就是所谓的：我不需要这些数据时就不去派生它。当我用完它时，那一刻我就把它释放掉。如果我再次需要它，我就重新生成它。你可以对所有部分都这样做，这需要修改代码和数据，但你是在遍历
that you hold in memory and saying, anything that I'm deriving, I just re-drive every time I use it. And that prevents me from, if you think through techniques we've talked about on here before, like memoization or caching and that kind of stuff, you know, those are great. Those are trading increased memory for decreased runtime,
你保存在内存中的东西，并说，任何我派生出来的内容，我都在使用时重新派生。这可以防止我——如果你回想一下我们之前讨论过的技术，比如记忆化（memoization）或缓存之类的——你知道，那些很棒，它们是用增加内存来换取减少运行时间，
but you can flip that around and actually say the reverse. Like I'll trade more runtime to have less memory impact. Yeah, that makes sense. Along those lines, another thing that I see a lot especially with Python developers or actually mostly with AI developers in any language is like missing back pressure. So I'll give you an example. Imagine if like you have one thread that loads data and another thread that does the ML right? Well doing the ML and and the auto grad and all that slow.
但你可以反过来，说：我愿意用更多的运行时间来换取更少的内存占用。是的，这很有道理。沿着这个思路，我经常看到的一件事，特别是在 Python 开发者中，或者实际上在任何语言的 AI 开发者中，就是缺少背压（back pressure）。我给你举个例子。想象一下，你有一个线程负责加载数据，另一个线程负责进行机器学习，对吧？嗯，进行机器学习、自动求导等等都很慢。
And so the load data thread will be able to load data faster than the other thread train the model. Yeah. And so you get to the point where you, you could take this to the limit. You have an infinite amount. You have the entire data set minus the little bit you've trained on already in memory and, uh, and then that first thread is done and in practice, what minus the little bit you've trained on already in memory and then that first thread is done.
所以加载数据的线程加载数据的速度会比另一个线程训练模型快。是的。所以你会达到一个临界点，你可以把它推到极限。你把除了已经训练过的那一小部分之外的整个数据集都放在内存里，然后第一个线程就完成了，实际上，除了已经训练过的那一小部分之外，第一个线程就完成了。
And in practice what happens is your pod gets killed or your computer gets killed or your computer catches on fire. Something happens where because that thread ran away, it generated way too much data for the other thread to consume. And so the way this is handled in Python is through generators. So the way it works in Python, and actually I'd love to know how you would do this in C++, but on the Python side there's functions where instead of a return value, you can actually
实际上发生的情况是，你的 Pod 被杀掉了，或者你的电脑死机了，或者你的电脑着火了。因为那个线程跑得太快，为另一个线程生成了太多数据，导致了一些问题。在 Python 中处理这个问题的方法是使用生成器（generators）。在 Python 中是这样工作的，其实我很想知道你在 C++ 中会怎么做，但在 Python 端，有一些函数，你不需要返回值，实际上你可以
have a return value, although very few people do this, but you typically would just return none, but along the way you're yielding. And so you can like have a for loop or in the for loop you're yielding values. And what that does is it allows like whoever is calling that function to consume that value right away, even though the function that they've called hasn't finished yet. And so you can have a generator that yields data to be trained on. And this is getting way down to the guts of the language. I'm definitely no expert, but I think the way it works is like, yeah, oh yeah, so the way this works is that the training model says, you know, give me, you know, the next value. And then when the data one, you know, goes and gets a new value and then calls yield, it's going to wait. It says, hey, I have new data that I can yield, but no one's asked for it. And so I'm just going to wait here. And then the training system can
有一个返回值，虽然很少有人这样做，通常你只会返回 None，但在过程中你会使用 yield。所以你可以有一个 for 循环，在循环中 yield 值。这样做的好处是，调用该函数的人可以立即消费该值，即使他们调用的函数还没有执行完。所以你可以有一个生成器来 yield 待训练的数据。这已经深入到语言的核心了。我绝对不是专家，但我认为它的工作方式是，是的，哦，是的，它的工作方式是训练模型说，你知道，给我下一个值。然后当数据线程去获取一个新值并调用 yield 时，它就会等待。它会说，嘿，我有新数据可以 yield，但没人要。所以我只是在这里等。然后训练系统可以
take however long it needs to take. It'll come back and say, hey, yield me something else, generate something else. And so in this way, you have back pressure. So I mean also when I was building the That's the sage replacement the eternal terminal It was a constant struggle to maintain back pressure so that at any time you could control C and Kill a program even if it was trying to send you you know an infinite amount of output Yeah, the C++ side is there like an equivalent of this or how would you design a system like this? Well I think you unintentionally segued to my to my next point anyways but that was perfect. No I mean I think what
花它需要的时间。它会回来并说，嘿，再给我 yield 一个东西，再生成一个东西。通过这种方式，你就有了背压。所以，当我在构建那个 Sage 的替代品——永恒终端（Eternal Terminal）时，维持背压也是一场持续的斗争，这样你随时都可以通过 Ctrl+C 杀掉一个程序，即使它正试图向你发送无限量的输出。是的，C++ 那边有类似的东西吗？或者你会如何设计这样的系统？嗯，我想你无意中引出了我的下一个要点，但这太完美了。不，我的意思是，我认为
you're saying is a version of sort of I'll say it's probably the more just generic approach which is as long as if you're in a multi-threaded environment you know producer and multi producer multi consumer and then what you want is a fixed sized queue. I always think about back pressure slightly different, where you're asking the producers to slow down, but it's sort of the same thing. So you have a pool of producers that are reading training data, downloading from URLs, whatever, and they're putting into a queue. At some point that queue could fill up, and if that queue fills up, and they're putting into a queue. At some point, that queue could fill up, and if that queue fills up,
你所说的是某种版本，我称之为更通用的方法，即只要你处于多线程环境中，你知道，生产者和多生产者多消费者，那么你想要的是一个固定大小的队列。我总是对背压的理解略有不同，即你要求生产者慢一点，但这本质上是一回事。所以你有一组生产者在读取训练数据、从 URL 下载等等，并将它们放入队列。在某个时刻，队列可能会填满，如果队列填满了，
then they're basically blocked waiting to send the next data into the queue. The consumers are pulling data out of the queue, and as soon as they empty something out, one of the producers gets to put their thing in, and you have to be careful with thread control, but with proper locking and everything, you can do that without much problems. And there's even lock free ways of having data structures
那么它们基本上就会被阻塞，等待将下一个数据发送到队列中。消费者从队列中取出数据，一旦它们清空了一些空间，其中一个生产者就可以放入他们的东西，你必须小心线程控制，但只要有适当的锁定和一切，你就可以毫无问题地做到这一点。甚至还有无锁的方法来构建数据结构
for doing that. And so in general that would be very similar to kind of how you're describing, but without maybe the keywords. There are ways to do sort of the same kinds of things with keywords, but like I think in general that would be how I would describe is like a set of threads consuming and a thread of a pool of threads producing, um, in the same way. To like level that up one notch and a lot of those, you know, um, things could be done this way is with something called a ring buffer. So if you talk about sort of a naive implementation of the queue
来做这件事。所以总的来说，这和你描述的非常相似，只是可能没有那些关键字。用关键字也可以做类似的事情，但我认为总的来说，我会将其描述为一组线程在消费，一组线程池在生产，以同样的方式。为了将其提升一个档次，很多事情都可以这样做，那就是使用所谓的环形缓冲区（ring buffer）。所以如果你谈论的是队列的一种简单实现，
every time you go download, you know, your training data and let's say it's images. So they're all going to be, you know, roughly the same resolution, right? That's something you will have done before you started. So you know probably generally how big one can be. But you say we're not going to do that initially. You're just going to, I have a JPEG, it's a hundred kilobytes. You go ask the operating system, give me a hundred kilobytes of memory. And then you say, oh're not going to do that initially. You're just going to have a JPEG. It's 100 kilobytes. You go ask the operating system, give me 100 kilobytes of memory. And then you say, oh, I'm waiting to put it in the queue, waiting to put it in the queue. OK, I put a pointer in the queue, a pointer to that 100
每次你去下载训练数据，假设是图像。所以它们的大小大致相同，对吧？这是你在开始之前就会做的事情。所以你可能大致知道一个图像会有多大。但你说我们最初不这样做。你只是，我有一个 JPEG，它是 100 KB。你去问操作系统，给我 100 KB 的内存。然后你说，哦，我在等把它放进队列，在等把它放进队列。好的，我把一个指针放进队列，一个指向那 100
kilobytes. The object takes that pointer out, pulls the image, frees the memory. And then the next person downloads the next thread, downloads the next image, 101 kilobytes. Gets a gets a new allocation right and so you're doing all this allocation free allocation free and we talked about there's expense to that as well as part of memory management and so what a ring buffer does is say if you know like the max size is gonna be 200 kilobytes or even just you know make it a lot bigger
KB 的指针。对象取出该指针，读取图像，释放内存。然后下一个人下载，下一个线程下载下一张图像，101 KB。得到一个新的分配，对吧？所以你一直在做这种分配、释放、分配、释放，我们谈到过，作为内存管理的一部分，这也有开销。所以环形缓冲区的作用是，如果你知道最大大小是 200 KB，或者甚至只是让它大一点，
a megabyte let's just say a megabyte and then say I'm gonna have the fixed size be 20 what I'm gonna do is each of the 20 slots in this sort of think about it as a ring has its own memory and a thread pulls from the ring to go read the image into that memory block that memory block then is consumed out when it gets to its turn and you have a head and tail pointer for where that is. It gets consumed out. So you get a limited number, but you also get to reuse the memory blocks. So each new producer can't produce until he gets a memory block, but then it's refilling. It doesn't have to go to the operating system again, right? Because it already has that memory. Your program owns and holds that memory.
比如 1 MB，然后说我要把固定大小设为 20。我要做的是，这 20 个槽位中的每一个——把它想象成一个环——都有自己的内存，一个线程从环中取出槽位，去把图像读入那个内存块。当轮到那个内存块时，它就被消费掉了，你有一个头指针和尾指针来标记位置。它被消费掉了。所以你得到了一个有限的数量，但你也能够重用内存块。因此，每个新的生产者在得到内存块之前都不能生产，但随后它会重新填充。它不必再次去问操作系统，对吧？因为它已经有了那块内存。你的程序拥有并持有那块内存。
And so that is reducing the amount of overhead to the operating system by saying in advance, if I offer some more limits, then I can reduce that interaction. And so you get the fixed size queue, you get queue API behavior, but the implementation is such that, you know, you need to ask the queue
所以这减少了对操作系统的开销，通过提前说明，如果我提供一些限制，那么我就可以减少那种交互。所以你得到了固定大小的队列，你得到了队列 API 的行为，但实现方式是，你需要向队列
for the memory to write to. And this is very, very common in embedded systems where you either want to, are required to completely avoid dynamic memory allocation because you don't really need it in that case. You just allocate to your program at startup, all the data for the ring, and then you never need it anymore, right?
请求内存来写入。这在嵌入式系统中非常非常常见，因为你要么想要，要么被要求完全避免动态内存分配，因为在这种情况下你并不真正需要它。你只需在启动时为你的程序分配环形缓冲区的所有数据，然后你就再也不需要它了，对吧？
You're reading into that buffer, and then you're just, you're doing your own memory manager, right? Your own little operating system to keep track of it. And I guess that's you're saving time because the pulling, getting the memory from the OS is a lot more expensive than keeping the references. Well, even if the memory, getting the memory was really, really cheap, you still have to call out to the operating system. The operating system is in a different context has to run work.
你读入那个缓冲区，然后你就在做你自己的内存管理器，对吧？你自己的小操作系统来跟踪它。我想你是在节省时间，因为从操作系统获取内存比保留引用要昂贵得多。嗯，即使获取内存非常非常便宜，你仍然必须调用操作系统。操作系统处于不同的上下文中，必须运行工作。
So even in the best case, the system call has overhead. And so you want to avoid that if you can. Um, but then like you said, right. If let's say you were doing a billion image reads, reads, that's a lot of allocation, deallocation, thrashing of the memory. Every one of them is slightly different sized. So you're getting all this fragmentation, and the OS is trying to handle all that.
所以即使在最好的情况下，系统调用也有开销。所以如果可以的话，你想避免这种情况。嗯，但就像你说的，对吧。假设你正在进行十亿次图像读取，那是大量的分配、释放，内存抖动。每一个的大小都略有不同。所以你得到了所有这些碎片，而操作系统正试图处理所有这些。
Versus if you manage it yourself, yes, your program is doing more. So I wouldn't reach for it in the beginning. But if you kind of know, hey, I'm at the point where I need to optimize, it's a great tool to reach for. Yeah, and it also reduces your variance because you've allocated this upfront,
相比之下，如果你自己管理它，是的，你的程序做得更多。所以我一开始不会去用它。但如果你知道，嘿，我已经到了需要优化的地步，这是一个很好的工具。是的，它也减少了你的方差，因为你预先分配了这些，
so it reduces the upper bound of what your program's gonna use. And your OS wouldn't know that, like in the example you were giving in Python, which is fine, because it's fast to write, it wouldn't know in advance how many consumers are gonna be pulling from the yield at the same time from the generator, right? advance how many consumers are going to be pulling from the yield at the same time from the generator, right? Or how many generators are going to be here? It can't know.
所以它降低了你的程序将要使用的上限。而你的操作系统不会知道这一点，就像你在 Python 中给出的例子一样，这很好，因为它写起来很快，它不会提前知道有多少消费者会同时从生成器的 yield 中拉取数据，对吧？或者会有多少生成器在这里？它无法知道。
So here, it would be very complicated to ask for it in this way. So this is the trade-off where instead you're sort of putting more limits on your system, but in exchange, you're getting better performance. Yeah, that totally makes sense. So the next one is a little similar. This one comes into, if you ever use protocol buffers or any kind of message where you're similarly, you're reading along and as you're processing data, you realize you need more memory to put stuff in. So in a protocol buffer, you have like a tree of messages, and as you're decoding them, you're finding new branches of the tree. You need to go get a little bit more memory, a little bit more memory, a little bit more memory to put that data in. And at the start, you don't know in memory how much data you're going to need. When you read a JPEG image,
所以在这里，以这种方式请求它会非常复杂。这就是权衡，你是在给你的系统施加更多的限制，但作为交换，你获得了更好的性能。是的，这完全说得通。所以下一个有点类似。这涉及到，如果你曾经使用过协议缓冲区（protocol buffers）或任何类型的消息，你同样是在读取，当你处理数据时，你意识到你需要更多的内存来存放东西。所以在协议缓冲区中，你有一个消息树，当你解码它们时，你会发现树的新分支。你需要去获取一点点更多的内存，一点点更多的内存，一点点更多的内存来存放那些数据。而在开始时，你不知道在内存中需要多少数据。当你读取 JPEG 图像时，
it's similar. If you want an array of zeros and ones, that is the resolution of your image, so you can put it into a neural network or whatever, you kind of know that size, but as you're reading the JPEG, you know, you're sort of how fast that conversion is happening varies as you go through the image. So if you didn't know the output size, it would just end up being dynamic the whole time. So then what you can do is something called an arena allocator.
它是相似的。如果你想要一个 0 和 1 的数组，也就是你图像的分辨率，这样你就可以把它放进神经网络或其他什么东西里，你大致知道那个大小，但当你读取 JPEG 时，你知道，你转换的速度随着你处理图像的过程而变化。所以如果你不知道输出大小，它最终会一直处于动态状态。那么你可以做的是所谓的竞技场分配器（arena allocator）。
An arena allocator basically says, every time you ask for memory, you ask it from this special allocator you have, and all it does is it never frees memory. It just keeps growing within the bounds. So you block out 10 megabytes, and as long as if you stay under 10, it just keeps growing within the bounds. So you block out 10 megabytes. And as long as if you stay under 10, it just keeps giving you new memory
竞技场分配器基本上是说，每次你请求内存时，你都从这个你拥有的特殊分配器中请求，它所做的就是从不释放内存。它只是在边界内不断增长。所以你划出 10 MB，只要你保持在 10 MB 以下，它就不断给你新的内存
from the 10 megabyte block. And then that whole block, even if you quote unquote free stuff from that you were using earlier, that whole block just stays with you. And then at the very end, you just delete the whole thing all at once. So instead of a thousand tiny allocations,
从那 10 MB 的块中。然后整个块，即使你“释放”了你之前使用的东西，整个块也一直保留在你这里。然后在最后，你只需一次性删除整个东西。所以与其进行一千次微小的分配，
you have one large allocation. And so that is also an advantage. Distinct from all of that, you know, let's say none of those strategies work, you know, you tried them all or whatever. Your other option, again, going to add runtime is having an on disk cache. So you can write things to disk that you know you aren't going to need for a while, similar to what the operating system might try to do for you. But you write things out to disk as you're reading them in and then, you know, I'm processing something, I'm deciding whether to use it or keep it. If I'm going to throw away most of the things I'm reading, then I just write to disk the ones that I want to keep.
你进行了一次大的分配。所以这也是一个优势。与所有这些不同的是，你知道，假设这些策略都不起作用，你知道，你都试过了或者其他什么。你的另一个选择，再次增加运行时间，是拥有一个磁盘缓存。所以你可以把你暂时不需要的东西写到磁盘上，类似于操作系统可能试图为你做的事情。但你在读入它们时把东西写到磁盘上，然后，你知道，我正在处理某样东西，我正在决定是使用它还是保留它。如果我要扔掉我读取的大部分东西，那么我就把我想要保留的东西写到磁盘上。
And then when I get to the later stage of my program, I'm reading them in one by one. And that way you don't just have this like growing, you know, list of all of the images before I am gonna, you know, process any of them. And so implementing your own disk-based cache or using a library which is gonna provide that for you, various levels of simplicity or sophistication
然后当我到达程序的后期阶段时，我一个接一个地读入它们。这样你就不会在处理任何图像之前，就有一个不断增长的、所有图像的列表。所以实现你自己的基于磁盘的缓存，或者使用一个为你提供该功能的库，各种简单或复杂的程度
you could do with that. Yeah, totally. Yeah, on the Python side, there's this tool called a Shelf. There's actually even better one, but it's not built into Python called SQLiteDict, but basically these act as if they're regular dictionaries. You wouldn't even know the difference. Like they implement all the dictionary APIs,
你都可以用它来做。是的，完全正确。是的，在 Python 端，有一个叫 Shelf 的工具。其实还有一个更好的，但它不是 Python 内置的，叫 SQLiteDict，但基本上这些表现得就像普通的字典。你甚至不会知道有什么区别。它们实现了所有的字典 API，
or most of them. But under the hood, all of that data is being put on disk. And so if you have a situation where maybe latency is not that important, but you're going to have to store a ton of information or you need it to persist from one run to another. But in this case, you just store a ton of it and you don't want to go over your limit. You can use these various tools. I think in C++ there's Mmap, right? Which like maps memory, maps disk memory. Yeah, but that's for a slightly different purpose, but yes.
或者大部分。但在底层，所有这些数据都被放在了磁盘上。所以如果你处于一种情况，也许延迟不是那么重要，但你将不得不存储大量信息，或者你需要它从一次运行持续到下一次。但在这种情况下，你只是存储了大量数据，而你不想超过你的限制。你可以使用这些各种工具。我想在 C++ 中有 Mmap，对吧？它映射内存，映射磁盘内存。是的，但那是为了稍微不同的目的，但是的。
Okay, all right. So what's the C++ equivalent if you need to like dump objects to disk and then bring them back later? Yeah, I mean, you could use SQLite, but yeah, ultimately there's no, unlike Python, there's not really a serialization built in, right? So it's generally not advised to just write your structure as a block of memory out. So you would need some serialization library to help you with that. Like protobuf for one of these things. Yeah, protobuf for, yeah, exactly.
好的，好的。那么如果需要把对象转储到磁盘然后再带回来，C++ 的等价物是什么？是的，我的意思是，你可以使用 SQLite，但是的，最终没有，不像 Python，没有真正内置的序列化，对吧？所以通常不建议直接把你的结构作为一块内存写出去。所以你需要一些序列化库来帮助你。比如 Protobuf 之类的东西。是的，Protobuf，是的，完全正确。
That makes sense. Cool, so yeah, I think this, we did a great job kind of covering a lot of this. If you have stories, other tools, don't hesitate to email us or post in the Discord. The Discord's actually even better because there is an audience there. If you email us, then we have to remember to go back to previous episodes. And if you're a longtime listener,
这很有道理。酷，所以是的，我想我们做得很好，涵盖了很多这方面的内容。如果你有故事、其他工具，请随时发邮件给我们或在 Discord 上发帖。Discord 其实更好，因为那里有听众。如果你发邮件给我们，我们就得记得回到之前的剧集。如果你是一个老听众，
you know that we're terrible at that. So go to the GitHub, sorry, go to the Discord and post ideas there, thoughts there. There's a community of folks, really interesting conversations happening over there. And it's really exciting to see. And Patrick and I do check it every now and then. And in general, we really appreciate everyone's engagement and also your support. We definitely appreciate your financial support through Patreon. You are our sponsor. There is no person paying us to say anything other than you folks. So we really appreciate it.
你知道我们在这方面很糟糕。所以去 GitHub，抱歉，去 Discord，把想法和思考发在那里。那里有一个社区，正在进行非常有趣的对话。看到这些真的很令人兴奋。Patrick 和我偶尔会查看它。总的来说，我们非常感谢大家的参与，也感谢你们的支持。我们绝对感谢你们通过 Patreon 提供的经济支持。你们是我们的赞助商。除了你们，没有人付钱让我们说任何话。所以我们真的很感激。
And we will put a bookmark in this one and we will catch you all next time. Music by Eric Barndaler. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share-A-Like 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and Share-A-Like in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们会在这一集打个书签，下次再见。音乐由 Eric Barndaler 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。